We have two commercials that we do smell
good.
I don't.
I don't know how to use windows.
Little Jimmy.
We just switched over to windows.
We just started using these alien ware
computers because a alienware sponsors a
lot of MMA fighter,
so I thought it would be a good thing to
do to support them.
They sponsor a lot of good guys like Pat
Barry and all these guys,
so we just switched over these alienware
computers.
Look at this fucking thing.
This is like a folding Imac.
It's a beast,
man.
It's ridiculous.
It's so big.
It's.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's if you're really into games,
it's like plant.
You can go on the road and take this
with.
You have your.
You're like one of those maniac gaming
people that just loves to like,
oh I know dudes who go on the road and
they do their gigs and then they bring
their laptops back to the hotel and they
play games all night and they'll just.
That's what they do everywhere.
Don't they want like a lot of guys like
Kevin Hart and those guys want like
video games in their dressing room.
Does he,
well,
I think maybe some guys you use games to
like take their mind off of the show to
like unwind a little bit.
Maybe.
Maybe you know,
if you.
I mean in the dressing room I would
think,
oh,
I want an address.
For him it was like water and beer,
but what else do you need?
Maybe some principals.
Coffee.
Yeah,
but like video games.
Like is it really.
I'm too busy panicking for a show,
man.
I'm,
I'm the worst.
Like A.
I always think it's going to go poorly.
I never think I'm going to do good.
I'm just terrible.
I'm not a professional.
Like I start calling up my act,
going that shit car.
I'm really psyched myself out.
That's a terrible thing to do.
I know,
man.
I got to stop that shit.
After 22 years,
the show's brought to you by the
flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
fleshlight,
entering the code name.
Rogan.
Save yourself 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men.
Jimmy,
have you ever used one of those
flashlights?
No,
but I hear they're pretty amazing.
Really.
You never use what I'm telling you,
man.
I know you masturbate.
We all do.
But uh,
and I still do on occasion.
I still sometimes I don't use the
flashlight,
but it's way better than beating off.
It is,
right?
You put lube on it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You Lube it up.
It's incredible.
It's like it's like a spectacular
vagina.
Not like a,
not like a decent one.
R One from a crow's.
Been fingered a few too many times.
Like a nice snug.
Oh,
so fuck it.
Like a warm,
friendly,
excited,
snug vagina can.
When you say fantastic vagina,
I just think that means there's no
fucking Larynix attached to the person.
Snug Vagina were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com.
That's.
Oh,
and it makers of Alpha,
brain,
troon,
tech sport,
True Tech.
Immune and new mood.
And if you have interest in any of this
stuff,
what they are as new tropics.
Most of them except for a couple of them
are a more sports us a performance like
I'm shroom tech sport,
which is an amazing supplement for
energy and endurance.
I take five of them before I do Jujitsu.
That's my thing.
Yeah,
it's fucking incredible.
It gives you amazing energy,
man.
Like,
oh look,
it's got a lot of vitamin B,
12 in it,
and this quarter's eps mushrooms,
which is a mushroom that these people
like high altitudes founded.
The cattle were eating and it was making
them more active so people started
supplementing their diet with it.
And this mushroom apparently helps you
process oxygen.
Do you know what I'm saying?
He's tired.
I'm always tired.
Well,
that sleep apnea thing,
have you got that workout?
I know I got like the thing you
suggested,
the mouth guard and helps,
but I may have central sleep apnea,
which is when your brain just is fucking
forgets to send the signal and uh,
so I might need the,
uh,
you and get the machine,
but I can't use it.
I just can't do it.
Like I slept for like nine hours last
night.
I'm just exhausted.
But maybe I think I might have maybe
have a deficiency somewhere.
A beach while I've been thinking about.
Well,
I think most people don't get the proper
amount of vitamins from their diet.
It would be nice if we did.
I mean,
ideally you would not want to take
supplements,
you know,
except uh,
I guess you would want to maybe to maybe
take nootropics or maybe take like for
some things,
like if you wanted to like a lot of B,
12,
you're not really gonna get the kind of
volume in an injectable b 12 or you
know,
even though an oral [inaudible] from
your diet,
like you'd have to eat like a lot of
food to get it.
It's,
it's,
it's really.
And I think be 12 comes from animal
protein to.
If I don't,
I might be wrong about that.
Is it okay to get it injected?
I might've made that up.
I should google it,
but I don't know how to use this.
I know a lot of people are doing.
I've heard that too.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
It's okay.
Yeah,
it's not poison.
I mean,
you're not,
you're not injecting toxic amounts of
it.
There's certain vitamins where you have
to be careful.
Um,
the,
you know,
there's,
there's vitamins that are absorbed in
different ways by the body.
I don't remember which one I think is
tricky.
I think if you get too much a,
but we are talking about like monstrous
amounts of the vitamins I had.
So as long as you're taking like
standard Multivitamin,
most that's been worked out a good solid
multivitamin.
They told me that I needed more whatever
the sun is.
D is that D,
which is crazy because I live in la.
Just to show you that's not really
outside though,
you know,
like chilling outside.
Let's go outside it more than I mean
normal like I don't not go outside.
Not like you would if you lived in like
the Caribbean or some shit all the time.
I mean an outside in Ohio people would
go to the sun in Ohio so it makes no
sense.
Like is there something that makes you
say you don't keep the DNA,
you like that you know,
there's a lot of people that have
deficiencies.
You,
you know,
your diet man.
I mean,
I don't know what you're eating,
but I don't think you're like super
careful about your diet.
Right east.
The reality is the reality is most of
our diets,
if you just look at what you're eating,
you're missing a lot of shit.
You're supposed to get on a regular
basis.
I need a multivitamin.
I got to do that,
man.
I just,
I want to,
but it makes me nauseous if I don't each
to.
Well,
you should never take vitamins without
food because the vitamins are absorbed
in your.
You mean they have to be in,
in
contact,
in conjuncture with fat.
They have to be fiber and carbohydrates,
like all that stuff you don't get.
You're not going to get the full effect
from a vitamin if you just eat the
vitamin like you have.
You should eat vitamins always with food
and also to avoid that,
that upset stomach fucking horrible.
Weak stomach sick.
Well,
that's a gross feeling.
I have a fucking mouthful of pills just
sitting in an empty stomach waiting a
breakdown.
It feels gross.
You want.
You have to resist the urge to Yack it
up.
You've had a coffee and an orange juice,
like the horrible combination like I
love people can order cereal with milk
and orange juice to kind of fuck you do
that.
How do you not vomit that?
Write up.
I'm coffee and they'll have a coffee on
the side.
They'll be taking sips to the cereal
aisle,
burping a or from last night,
orange juice and the coffee.
Just fucking brutal combination.
Just a putrid stomach.
Oh,
let's get through these commercials.
on it.
We also have new kettlebells.
Kettlebells are in.
Finally,
if you're interested in Kettlebell
fitness,
we have a little simple online tutorial
on [inaudible] dot com and if you're
really interested and you want to get
the best videotapes possible,
go online and buy.
Buying for my friend Steve Maxwell.
Steve Maxwell's an amazing trainer and
I've had the pleasure of working with
them a few times and I met him first and
foremost from his dvds.
He has these incredible,
a tech guy.
He's like a very technical guy when it
comes to Kettlebell training and he's
like Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
black belt.
He's a real bad ass.
So the dude is incredible shape.
I mean,
I believe,
I don't wanna I don't wanna miss status,
but babies close to 60 years old.
Oh Wow.
The guy's incredibly fit.
I mean really a genius when it comes to
a physical fitness and conditioning.
So if you're interested in,
he's just my friend.
I'm not profiting from ms dot any way.
Go check out Steve Maxwell stuff because
it really truly is the best.
Uh,
Mike [inaudible] got some really good
dvds as well.
And then there's one from a dragon
door.com,
but I really love called the extreme
kettlebell cardio workout.
I forgot the gentleman who is doing the
exercises,
but he's a fucking bad ass.
Um,
so we have kettle bells for sale at
[inaudible] dot com.
They are the best you can buy.
These are your kettle bells.
These kettlebells will last you
literally for the rest of your fucking
life.
They will.
They'll find them after the next
apocalypse.
Archeologists will try to decipher what
the fuck these things.
Where next year,
skeleton just holding one of these hands
that said it's not as cheap as we can
sell them,
but they're not that cheap.
It's very difficult to ship these cannon
balls through the fucking mail and and
still profit from it.
So.
But these are these a lifetime
investment and I don't use anything
else.
You don't need a gym membership.
You don't need shit.
You need a backyard and some exercises
and some black site or even you don't
even need a back yard.
If you have enough room inside your
house.
Like if you have a big room where you
can,
you don't ever need to go to a gym,
you will get a fucking ruthless workout
from Kettlebell.
What does that he was doing right there.
He was like,
he was like kind of taking it and
letting us handle between his legs.
What is he working on there?
Well,
he's showing us.
The beautiful thing about kettlebells is
that everything you do,
everything.
You're working a bunch of different
groups of muscles.
You're not just what people think of.
Like what does that exercise for your
shoulders would.
What an exercise should always really be
for his functional movement.
You should be enhancing your ability to
move functionally and that doesn't
always do that when you have like
isolated exercises like curls are like
bench presses or shit like that.
Like that's not really how the body is
supposed to work,
right?
Your body supposed to work in a group,
everything together.
I mean,
and that's,
that's what I find is the most
applicable to athletics.
When I started doing kettlebells I got,
I just got a lot stronger.
I got a lot stronger as far as my
Jujitsu and my wind got better.
My,
my,
my ability to,
to like push a pace got better.
It's like you get it,
you get a muscular endurance from kettle
bells that's very rare,
uh,
doing other kinds of exercises and you
get big from it too,
man.
And you don't have to do it that often.
You know,
these are,
it's a brutal workout.
It's so hard that it breaks your tissue
down and then,
you know,
you need a few days off before you can
do it again.
You know,
you might be able to do something else
in between like some kickboxing or
something,
but when you're first starting to do
kettlebells,
you will be fucking amazed at how bad
you get your ass kicked by.
One 35 pound kettle bell because you go
through all these exercises and it feels
easy for the first,
like 15 seconds and then you realize,
you know,
you got like seven more minutes to go,
which,
you know,
those are metal,
right?
How solid iron.
Those are solid iron kettle bells.
I have them in my gym.
Um,
I should probably use them,
but they're awesome to keep until the
elliptical Joe fucking great too,
man.
I have a workout I do on the elliptical.
That is an unbelievably hard.
It,
you do a warm up for like 10 minutes.
And then I do these sprints of 30
seconds.
As hard as I can go at a high level,
you know,
as literally as hard as I can go.
Like I'm running for my fucking life.
And then take 30 seconds off in 30
seconds just,
Oh,
just try to catch your breath.
Try to bring your heart rate down and
then go to war again.
The next 30 seconds.
How long do you do this?
For?
As long as I can do it.
Usually I get 10 to I can go.
I can do it 10 times.
As hard as you can.
As hard as I can.
Yeah,
it's not that much.
If I was an athlete,
that would be pathetic.
You know,
if I was a professional athlete,
you probably have a much better one than
I do.
Dude,
that's an awesome workout and it really
applies to,
to physical things like applies for me
when I hit the bag,
it applies for me to Jujitsu.
Like I can see that I can improve my
cardio by doing that.
So people like make fun of the
elliptical,
but you can work your fucking ass off in
the elliptical.
You just have to decide either you have
to decide how to do it.
You can,
you can go bananas on that thing and get
an incredible workout.
We also have,
um,
but we also have battle ropes.
These are the latest and greatest
gadgets in the MMA training for like all
these guys that are strength and
conditioning coaches,
a lot of them are using these huge ropes
that you manipulate and they call them
battle ropes and the ones that we have
are 40 fucking feet long and you hurled
these ropes up and down and it's an
incredible workout for your core and for
your wind and for your grip strength,
your grip.
It's so incredible for your grip
strength because you're connecting to
this gigantic heavy moving object and
you're swinging it with your whole body
and not like a curl and not like doing
tricep extensions.
That's like silly girly shit.
You want to get like a real
fucking manly workout.
You swing ropes around like a savage,
like this motherfucker and what you do
is fast forward a little so we can get
to one of the exercises.
I doing it before.
It's like he fucking brutal.
Yeah,
he has it.
I've used my own argument string before,
but nothing like this.
Your old arguments during mild arguments
during.
What does that mean?
It's not as good as these battle ropes.
They're like,
this guy's shoes.
He's got those,
those toe shoes.
What that is.
I were,
but I'm very embarrassed by like,
here's,
here's one of them you wear.
Those do,
they're bad ass.
The,
the best for working out,
but they're the gas footwear ever known
to man.
How many toes are actually like
separated this telephone?
Five.
See You and Robert Kelly wearing those
things would be little.
A little man personally with my,
with my fanny pack.
Bravo.
Wears them around everywhere and
anywhere.
His,
his,
uh,
his little toe things.
He wears those bitches ever leave time
I've ever seen those where I was like,
yes,
that that's acceptable.
Is the sunset.
Jesus guy wears them now.
And I'm like,
you know,
that's perfect for you.
Perfect for a sentence where she.
As far as cost,
that's what it'd be like.
Jesus would wear toe shoes anyway.
Uh,
for all this information about the
nootropics,
the vitamins,
about the supplements for,
for
athleticism and serotonin boosting,
new mood,
all that shit.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
I believe in this stuff.
I use it.
I the only reason why I'm we sell it at
all or I have any affiliation with it
because I was using new nootropics and
vitamins long before I ever was
affiliated with on it.
It's something that I've always been
interested in.
I've been taking vitamins most of my
life and I very strongly believe in
supplements and healthy diet and it's
all very important to me,
but what it's also important is having
people never feel like they get ripped
off.
So if you order anything like Alpha
brain and you try it,
your first 30 pills,
you get 100 percent money back
guarantee.
You don't even have to return the
product to say,
this sucks.
Giving my money back.
That is how,
first of all,
how confident we are that you're going
to enjoy it and it's good.
You're going to feel a benefit from them
and be how it's.
Look,
I don't.
Nobody wants to get ripped off.
I don't want to get ripped off.
I don't want to rip you off.
We're just trying to sell good stuff and
make some money.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code name,
Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all orders.
Get Your fucking brain supplements on
Sun.
I really need that shit.
You need to for my energy.
Do we have a bottle here?
Brian?
Is there a bottle of alphabet?
Atlanta?
I think think I lost it in yesterday's
confusion,
but I'll double check.
Alright.
Cue The music.
Little Jimmy Norton here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
what did you do?
The Joe Rogan experience podcast by
night.
My pal stand up comedian.
Extraordinary and mixed martial arts
fanatic.
Jimmy Norton.
Thank you joe.
Little Jimmy.
You like Chael Sonnen?
Who's.
What's,
what's going on with you?
I can't wait.
I know it's going to be crazy to be
there live while that's happening and to
get the call it.
I got chills just thinking about it.
You have a great job man.
It's the best job of all time.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
So it's amazing that it exists.
You know,
I mean,
when I first started doing me and data,
we've talked about this a bunch of
times.
We first started working for the UFC and
you would tell people that you're
involved in it.
It's almost like you're talking about
porn,
right?
That's what cage fighting was like and
now it is just incredibly mainstream
thing.
It's really interesting.
It's an embarrassing thing for New York
too that it's not legal there and we all
know other nonsense is going on,
but it's embarrassing for Neela.
It makes New York looked like this
irrelevant all old thinking place and
the more boxing and I watched boxing.
It's a great sport but I can't enjoy
anything.
Like I enjoyed the UFC.
It's really weird.
Like people get mad at me.
I know and aches.
I'm such a fucking whore for this,
but it's like I don't,
I don't want to hear about baseball
because a lot of baseball players I've
met had been Dick's.
A lot of football players had been
dicks,
but at all the UFC guys,
you're great.
Like I've,
I haven't met any of them that were
assholes.
I've met most of the big ones.
Every one of them is nice with the fans
and is nice to us when they come in.
Well,
I've always said that people are.
I think every man needs to learn at
least something about martial arts and
something about how to defend yourself
to get your that sorta chimpanzee
bullshit out of your system that makes
most men become dicks.
I think a lot of people are dicks simply
because they're frustrated physically
like their body feels like physically,
like confined by its inaction,
but confined by the stress of everyday
life and having to pay bills and just
shit is always built up inside of you.
If you don't do something to blow that
out physically and balance your body
back,
I think you can.
You can have a hard time in this life
and you can overreact to people.
You could maybe be already be at a five
and this guy says something and you
crank it up to eight and you're like,
come off.
He,
he yourself feel like a dick.
Like,
why did I do that?
What the.
But you realize what it is.
You're,
you're,
you're already wound up.
You don't even realize it.
You're,
you're going through life.
Wound up something like martial arts can
get that out of your system called and
told me I'm a fucking car gangster
because I talk so much shit in the car,
but it's a very reasonable and somebody
is six three.
He's a gangster.
All is so fucking funny.
It really is the fucking funniest guy
alive.
He's so funny.
He's such a treasure.
He's one of those guys that you like.
You have to experience him live to,
to get the full effect of his comedy.
Yeah.
When,
when he,
uh,
did tough crowd.
I never got a chance to see them live
that much because I was already living
in La and he was almost always in New
York.
But when we did a tough crowd,
he would go up and to stand up to the
honest to God.
I forgot how funny he is.
I was,
I'm with you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And we did it together.
I don't know who else was on it.
I don't remember.
He was so funny.
Oh my God.
He just.
Because he.
And here's the thing,
we'll call them the amazing.
It's like he never gets angry at the
audience are not going with them and I'm
like,
he just,
he addresses it.
All right folks just plow,
but he doesn't.
And Louise in a weird way the same way,
like they throw out what they throw out
and they don't react emotionally.
They allowed the audience to have their
own emotion and that's a weakness in my
performance is I try to fucking.
I bring the emotion and it's just like
he did it all for a stupid.
It's not having no faith in the words.
So that's what I'm saying to myself.
It's sort of a cro me,
there's a fine line between like I would
hear that Jay Leno would go and work out
his monologue and he would do it flat
and he did it on purpose that way we'd
work it out.
The comedy Magic Club.
He would do those jokes on purpose flat
because he didn't want to have to jazz
them up.
He didn't want to say you wanted to find
out if the concept on its own is good
and from there you can jazz it up,
but that's a gross feeling.
When you're trying to jazz something up,
sort of artificially.
Yeah,
I prefer to work out material the same
way.
I mean that's what a pompous ass comic
would say,
but I really do it the seller with no
energy completely deadpan and just see
how the words work without with.
Because you don't want to get a laugh
going whatever face you make like a
fucking rye look.
You want it to be funny because it's
funny but it's hard to do that because
a,
it bombs a lot of the time.
How do you write?
Do you write your material?
Like do you like get an idea and say,
all right,
when we sit down and think of how I
would put this idea to the audience or
do you.
Do you like blogs and pull your jokes
out of it?
No,
I just want a lot of guys do it.
I just go on because I'm at the cellar
every night,
so I went on to live with Travolta,
like I just shot this special and I was
like,
alright,
I'm done with that fucking hour,
so I want to start over because anymore
that doing that material again is
repulsive to me.
Never want to say those words again.
I fucking hate it.
I'm sick of watching it.
I think they did it.
So now I want to do something else.
So thank God Travolta had all this
malarkey happened.
So I just went on and started talking
about Travolta and uh,
you know,
trying to grab guys Cox to the thing and
I had fun with it and then I,
I kind of built it up.
I was waiting to hear what your take on
it would be.
As soon as I saw it in the news,
I said I would love
to talk to Jimmy about this because on
one hand you got to say,
okay,
there got to be a lot of guys who just
sucked his dick because he was doing it
that often.
If he was pulling it out that often on
these [inaudible] I,
I bet it's probably because there's a
bunch of them were jumped on that
grenade.
Do you know how many.
Whose fault is that?
Really?
I don't.
I don't fault him because I couldn't
believe I believed them though because
the language,
like I believe the one who accused Al
Gore because the language they use is
language I've used.
Like when he said that Al Gore,
like the woman said that he said,
could you rub my receptors or whatever.
I'm like,
oh,
that's a typical fucking perv move.
You use our literal and appropriate
language so they can accuse you of
trying to get,
you know.
Excuse me,
would you,
would you mind rubbing my chakras?
You know,
and we both know what I'm saying,
but she can't get mad at you.
My Dad,
when I was a kid,
my dad always said,
hey,
that's your paper.
Every time I was like,
what's this?
And then it was like I was in fifth
grade.
Right.
Well you're talking about should
probably avoid saying suck my paper
because I think that would be easy to
decipher.
I don't think you'd have to call him the
fucking guys who broke the Jap code to
figure out how to put a paper is.
Well your honor,
we can't say for sure.
It was his penis sucked my paper.
It was very ambiguous.
It could be anything,
but I still use it now.
You know,
I use it with girls that do you really,
for some reason the two of you playing
with your nipples and you look down and
just just tell her to kiss your people.
That's even creepier and more childlike
noodles or kissimmee paper may present
my noodles.
I know I never used words I never asked.
I'm like,
I do this silent and it's funny.
I was going to do some of this on,
on Leno tonight,
but I just said I had to bail on a
little bit because I was on with Justin
Bieber.
It was all fucking 15 year old girls and
I'm like,
what?
They've never gotten a happy ending
massage.
Um,
so I kind of bailed on the sosh drove
ultimate cheer.
I didn't do any of it.
That's a good move because you probably
save the minds of all those different 15
year old kids from the creepy ideas you
have that are based on truth,
but all of a sudden they're going to be
driving by these massage power's going,
which one of these jerk you off?
Does that Daddy?
Does that one jerk guys off?
Or even worse,
you're gonna put on pulp fiction and go,
wow.
He grabbed the penis and then a couple
of minutes later grabbed the scrotum.
I wish I would have committed to the
travolta stuff.
I'm kind of mad at myself that I went
away from it and I just wanted to stop.
Do you see what Letterman did?
A bieber the other last week I heard it
was uncomfortable.
Yeah.
That was really what was like,
oh,
he,
uh,
we could probably show it,
but he,
he got a new tattoo and then letterman
was kind of acting weird and then tried
to grab his tattoo and he had just got
it done.
So it was like bloody and stuff and he
wouldn't.
He was.
And B was like,
no,
stop,
stop.
But he wouldn't stop like that extra
second and then it was just like a
beaver mispronounce something and then
he's like,
yeah,
that's Canadian high school for you.
But the whole attitude of the whole
thing seemed very good
in chapel.
Yeah.
The crowd was the crowd with them where
they call.
I don't know man.
We could watch it if you want to.
I'll find out.
I'm serious.
Well,
what was the problem he had with
them?
Was it just he didn't want to be
interviewing Justin Bieber's I wouldn't
want.
I don't know man.
I think he was just trying to act like
the old man,
the old grumpy dad that started coming
like just had a weird.
It was a weird sometimes man,
you just can't.
You don't jibe with someone you don't
realize until you're out there talking
to them,
but you're fighting for your life.
You know,
I had to get off a conversation and you
know,
as comics,
I mean we've all gone for something that
was just ridiculous in hindsight,
but in the moment,
you know,
you think that would be funny if I grab
his tattoo and just fucking hold onto
the little fog that it just gets cricket
and you're like,
I got to let go and come back to my
seat.
But he'll laugh and think like,
who?
Like what does he do?
Does he try to get inside the mindset of
a Justin Bieber who is further for them?
Justin Bieber.
Then David Letterman,
human spectrum in the United States of
America.
I'm pretty fucking Goddamn far apart,
but he probably doesn't even think.
He probably just does what he wants to
do without fear of it not working.
That's fine.
Why let him into it?
He probably is not afraid there's not
going to work.
Yeah.
It just gives it a shot.
I was worried though.
I mean it's like 20 years of stand up.
Finally.
I was able to adjust and make it a
decent appearance,
but it was like that could've been
fucking death.
Cookies was we went to break because I
did better than I thought you'd do,
which made me kind of laugh.
Funny.
Yeah,
that's.
I've done those shows at the improv
before where they have some sort of a
high school tour and you look out there
and at the Improv and a professional
show,
you look out this 14 and 15 year old
kids.
You're like,
what's going on here?
Yeah,
what am I going to do that?
Or he went up and went extra dirty.
It was ridiculous.
Our.
He went up and I was like,
did you go extra dirty for those kids?
He goes,
yeah,
Kinda didn't work.
Oh Yeah,
you kidding me?
Yeah.
I mean people were freaking out.
I mean,
you're literally talking about the first
time a kid has ever heard anything
remotely like that.
I mean when you're 13 and 14,
especially when we did these shows,
it was a few years back,
you know,
I don't know how much,
how many kids were getting online but
to,
to see,
to watch comedy online,
but to see it like live and in person
like that here it,
they had never experienced anything like
a standup comic doing a dirty act in a
nightclub in Hollywood.
Like they were blown away.
It was crazy.
Well these were all girls who were 15
year old girl,
16 girls in front of him to that creepy
as fuck.
Screaming fucking.
It's uncomfortable.
You're like,
I'll never know what that's like.
They actually made them do it for me
cause yeah,
you all do promos,
you'll go stand there.
So the three of us were standing there
with Leno at the end just doing the
promo to,
to the news channels and he goes,
just give a scream,
uh,
for Jim.
So we made all the girls scream from and
it was kind of,
it felt nice as a nice for once.
I mean I knew it wasn't sincere.
Beautiful it.
I enjoyed it for the moment.
Nice.
Here's the,
uh,
the Letterman bieber thing.
It's 10 from TMZ.com
explaining this to me.
Is that a new tattoo?
Oh God.
How many do you have?
I have a couple.
Just a couple will tell me that's the
last one.
No,
no it is.
You don't.
I mean honestly,
like how does that help?
How does that help how you looked at
ever tattoo?
How does it not?
I mean,
it doesn't,
not help the way I look into expressing.
Yesterday my album came out as a day for
me,
so you know,
I got bullied.
Hey.
This is a brand new.
Awesome.
Those were areas
you did just then you went,
hey.
Hey.
Yeah.
Canadians.
The Canadian.
Now mom can't be pleased with the
tattoos.
Mom,
you know,
she's a mom.
Have a tattoo.
She does.
No,
I don't think so.
Does Dad ever dare to.
Oh,
do me a favor.
Don't go nuts.
You know what I mean?
Because more and more.
You see like the mural and the like the
sistine chapel on.
It's too much.
I'm not going from the 16th chapel.
This is hilarious.
Canadian high school.
Can I tell you what's so great about
watching that as a comic?
When he said Sixteenth Chapel,
you could watch letterman as a comedian
go,
oh God just gave me that.
You relish the moment and he knew it was
going to get a laugh,
whatever he said.
I thought that was great.
Yeah,
that was very funny.
I didn't think there was anything wrong
with that at all.
Oh No,
no.
I mean that's what people are saying.
No,
they.
They attacked that Bieber fans.
Fans are silly.
You look,
kick him off looking great.
Yeah.
He handled it well.
Beaverton too upset by it.
No,
he seemed like he went with the flow
really well and I thought that was
really funny.
I don't know why anybody would have a
problem with that.
That was just letterman being letterman.
He's the best man.
What would you do in that situation?
Would you,
if you were like on pet,
would you commit to the stuff or hey,
this is what I was going to talk about,
or would you like make an adjustment of
your head?
I don't know.
I don't like doing those.
I got to tell you,
I don't,
you know,
it's this,
it's a craft in itself constructing the
five minute set for,
for talk shows and there's totally
different like line of standup comedy.
It's like there's your standup comedy
and then there's these weird portal
stops that you do and one of them is the
five minute set on a tonight show.
Squeaky clean or least except for like
some innuendo but nothing too crazy.
Nothing political,
nothing really ultra controversial,
right?
And No,
no ability to expand upon anything for
five minutes.
It's so quick know you're in,
you're out.
You just got to get a few points across
real quick and all your best bets are
two and a half minutes long.
So it's not like you're going to do two
bits and then bail.
So you're going to kind of chop stuff up
a little bit or construct a set for,
you know,
you know what I mean?
I couldn't even show a clip from the
special they want to when I show a clip
and I'm like,
Hey,
like what do I do?
The thing about Sharpton dying,
do I do the thing about the fucking
Moscow,
none of that will work,
so we showed a promo for the special,
which it was a very funny promo,
but the standup itself I couldn't show
because I knew none of it would play and
it's all too fucking long.
It's all more than 40 seconds of course,
because you have points,
you have points of view,
you have ideas.
It's real hard to express any of that in
five minutes.
I found that every like short set that I
ever did,
I just felt like shit.
That makes me feel good to hear you say
that though because it's like you feel
like as a comic,
like why can't I just go out there and
fucking hit home runs when I do these
things for five or six minutes in the
club either.
I mean it's.
Look,
it is what it is.
It's a great promotion of vehicle.
Obviously it's an honor to be on the
tonight show as always and when you do a
set,
definitely people are going to see it
and it's going to help your career.
No doubt about it,
but it's not a bet,
a really good representation of your
standup,
a good representation of your standup is
in a club,
you know,
and that's really what we do.
You know,
even theater,
I mean theater is great because you can
get more people to come out and see you
and you know,
you still still can be a lot of fun,
but ideally if a theater is at nine
point nine of a comedy clubs at 10.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's only a little bit less to do with
it,
but a club like 200 seater man,
you know when you're right there and
you're fucking it,
you're so tuned into the crowd and the
crowd,
they,
they're having so much fun.
It's like the,
the,
the amount of laughs and the,
the full energy you get of killing in
front of 200 people.
It's very,
very,
very few things in life.
Are that powerful?
Bounces back at you like you feel it
when it's again,
it's a small room,
like the comedy cellar in New York.
Just fuck it.
Just pound the store.
Yeah,
original rule in the store.
You're killing on that stage.
It just comes right back all over your
comedy works.
Denver.
Um,
I've only done that once.
I did well there,
but I didn't draw that right there.
Oh yeah,
true.
Okay.
How long ago was this?
I have four or five years ago.
How dare you?
I know.
I would love to do it and go back.
Yeah,
I think things have changed.
Yeah.
I think the,
uh,
you know,
the Internet has helped all of us sort
of get,
get our voice out.
I don't know,
man.
I feel like I can't get me fucking kind
of internet buzz it all.
Everything I do gets 5,000
views.
That's all you have to do is do a
podcast.
Why don't you do what Anthony's doing if
you did your own podcast,
I know it's hard because you're on.
Oh,
and a five hours a day.
But if you did your own podcast once a
week,
no,
once,
just something people love that it's
free.
They can get your show on Xm,
but they have to pay or they have to go
illegal and go with tolerance and risk
behind,
creeping up your ass asshole microscope,
you know.
Um,
but if you give them something for free,
like end into his shows,
not just Jimmy oriented,
you know,
it's like a gang of people.
If you had your own podcast,
that was all you.
Well I guess you do the music thing,
but that's not a serious show too.
Yeah.
But I'm also,
I don't,
I don't know if I'm allowed to
contractually to be honest.
You might not be allowed to do a
podcast.
They allow me to perform on them.
I don't know if they'll allow me to
actually do one and market it as a Jim
Norton vehicle because it's a different
platform.
I don't know.
Hm.
That's interesting.
If they could play it,
I don't see why they would have a
problem with it,
you know,
like if,
if they also played it,
you know,
because that's what we do with them.
You know,
we were,
we have a broadcast and we're on Sirius.
We go on to Onh right.
But we just,
uh,
we just give it to them,
which is give it to them for free.
It's just smart thing to do because
you're right,
nobody wants to pay for Shit and we want
to do an on a podcast,
but we just put it up,
give them an hour a week for free to get
people who aren't into the show,
into the shell and mean expanding
marketing.
Everybody understands why I don't,
I probably could have just said that and
not explained it.
But then some people think,
well that's all they would need is that
hour a week.
You know,
they'll just take that hour week and
they'll add it to the five hours the
Corolla puts out,
puts out,
you know,
a couple of hours a week.
And I mean if you really stop and think
about how many great podcasts are out
there right now,
there's,
you know,
how many,
how many hours do you have to fucking
know people.
It's a weird sort of a situation where
it gets to.
There's a saturation point where
especially ones like ours that are like
three hours long sometimes.
How many,
how many of those can you have?
You know,
will you have a bigger name going into
it anyway?
I think I starting up and trying to do
something like that.
It's a lot harder.
I mean you have a trauma.
It's 600,000
people on twitter,
so I on a thousand at this point.
I remember when you had like fucking 80.
I remember when I was like,
I was like 12 when you were like 80.
Like all right,
I'll catch Rogan and boys.
You fucking just quadruple.
Well Louise got like one point $3
million now.
I looked at that but he's on fire.
Doesn't Tosh have something credible?
Isn't tosh like 7 million or something
and I'm going to get 4 million,
something like that,
but I'm going to be five.
But uh,
yeah he's probably the biggest comic or
oh,
Kevin Hart,
Kevin Hart and Tosh what?
Kevin is A.
I keep hearing about him,
like killing it.
I keep hearing about him.
Like I don't know where he's at but I
keep hearing like,
you know how funny it shows our.
I've never watched him.
I hear he's counted.
His Shell is funny and comedy central
like I haven't heard any comics shitting
on him either.
No,
I keep hearing from the audiences that
it's hilarious.
I've got to go.
I got to see him.
I got to see Daniel Tosh.
6 million people.
It's too many.
Damn it,
son.
Too many good for him,
man.
You don't need all that.
Yeah,
he deserves it.
He deserves it.
He's fucking funny.
God,
I want a couple.
Yeah,
we've got to figure out how to get you
some go to figure out.
Hey,
look serious.
It's fucking awesome.
I love serious.
I love the,
the high definition sound.
The,
the music is in.
I mean,
it sounds really good when it comes
through satellite.
It doesn't sound like a radio.
It sounds.
Yeah.
It's much better than radio sound and
it's coming from the fucking sky.
I totally support that.
You know,
I love the fact that I can just click on
classic vinyl and then I hear,
uh,
you know,
on the road again by Bob Seger,
like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
it's like,
it's worth it to me.
It's totally worth it.
I love that.
You know,
you guys are on.
I listened to Howard still at listened
to.
Um,
uh,
I listened to Ron and Fez.
It's,
it's totally worth it to me.
But the Internet is the future and
somehow know the Internet is going to
get into people's cars and when that
happens,
when that happens,
it's going to be real hard.
It's like,
it's going to be real hard to,
to sell Internet radio,
right?
It's going to just have to be
advertising base,
like podcasts are.
They're going to have to change their
business model to make money a different
way because you're not going to go to
get him to fucking pay for it.
What's going to stop you?
It's not just that they're going to stop
using it.
Like why would they use it when you have
things like spotify and all these
different ways of getting to tell you.
I have both right now,
satellite radio and,
and my iphone sets up where I have
spotify or Pandora or anything like
that.
It's just easier.
Like I,
you know,
it's,
you still have to do shit with all the
things that you have to type in the
station that you want if you're using,
you know,
Pandora or have to do that.
There's more than just turning it on and
hitting a button and that's the,
that's what's still going on.
Like I still use satellite radio more
because I just turned it on and Bam.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
So there's not too many steps to go
through steps.
Yeah.
But that's going to change and there's
less and less and less steps are
happening as you go on.
The other thing is that you have to be
with satellite,
you know,
you have to be in a place where you
could see the satellite.
That's why it dies out when you go into
bridges and shit,
that's the internet.
So the same way you go fucking
someplaces,
you don't have any internet at all.
That's true.
So there's gonna be some places maybe
you know.
Well,
I don't know.
It doesn't make any sense to still do
the same thing regular radio get.
They just put receivers in the Lincoln
tunnel and I can get fucking.
You can listen to q one.
Oh,
four.
Three in case you haven't heard Brown
eyed girl.
Enough Time's gone into fucking jersey.
Can you get a satellite radio under the
tongue?
No,
but they could put in receivers.
They probably don't feel it's worth it
yet.
I mean,
real regular radio does,
but they don't need to do.
They must hate the Internet to see what.
Do they hate the Internet?
No,
I don't think so.
I mean,
uh,
they,
they understand what a promotional tool
it can be too.
But I mean they understand that the
threat.
I mean,
it certainly is.
Once Wifi is and cars,
everything's going to be in trouble.
Well,
the thing is when,
when serious first came out or when
satellite radio in general first came
out,
it was really like a dream come true.
Like,
oh my God,
like I can get radio in my car that's
uncensored.
Like somehow or another,
some Bozo hasn't stepped in and made it
so that if you say the wrong fucking
noise with your mouth,
you get locked up in a cage and they get
to forfeit,
forfeit all your assets and that's just
nutty shit when it comes to censorship
that people don't understand,
like how damaging that is.
And in all the time that satellite radio
is bid on,
how much different are things really?
I mean,
it's not like anybody got hurt the same
fucking people are listening to it.
It's not like all of a sudden you know,
you guys being completely,
totally honest with all the words that
you'd ever wanted to use.
It's not like that.
All of a sudden it started.
People were running out in the streets
and fucking cutting off heads and
jumping off bridges.
Nothing changed.
So therefore it's bullshit.
Therefore it's useless.
It's not like it's contributing to the
downfall of society.
Well,
the FCC just lost a big case to,
for Fox.
Uh,
they lost a huge fucking case.
Mr Graham court about A.
I don't know if it was about just quick
utterances,
but they they,
they removed
a lot of the fines.
I think that Fox has got thrown out
there,
so the FCC just to go and we knew they
would because they're fucking greedy and
they're talking.
They won't just lay off.
It's so creepy when they chased after
stern when all that shit was in the
news,
it was so creepy.
It felt like it felt like good against
evil.
That's really what it felt like.
It felt like someone out there trying to
entertain people and he's getting
attacked by the manner in which he's
entertaining is unsuitable for this
particular type of transmission and
because of that,
the federal government steps in and it's
so crazy that anybody would think that
that's a good idea.
It's allowed to get to be actual law and
still reinforced and in this day and
age,
what people like Tim Winter in the
fucking a PTC,
the parents television council,
they write most of the complaints.
They're the ones who do all the fucking
complaints and the stupid fcc still
actually takes them seriously and
listens to them.
It's enraging.
It's like when the Italian American
society or whatever the fuck it is,
was getting angry at the surprise.
You know,
it's like just there's certain things
where political correctness become such
a fucking hamper.
Two,
a real dialogue to real conversations to
anyone who thinks that he's being pc as
is appropriate is a dope.
Anyone who subscribes that thinking is a
dumb motherfucker.
What you're saying that you don't think
that people like Tony Soprano of every
existed.
Do you pay attention to history?
Like what?
Where are you getting this from?
Stupid lucky you're going to protest the
way they're being depicted,
being depicted the way they really are.
There's plenty of people like that that
are real people.
It just doesn't mean that that's all
Italian 20 you only protecting retards.
The only protect them,
the dopiest amongst us,
amongst us that would,
you know,
look at all Italians as if they were all
gangsters.
Now because of the Sopranos and why has
nobody ever objected to a positive
profile?
This is why they're thinking is flawed
because they're saying the profiling is
wrong and generalizing is wrong,
but they never mind when they're
generalized positively,
they nevermind a positive profile or a
pleasant sweeping generalization,
so that's why they're fucking phony.
We just don't like a negative thing.
So there's certain things they want you
to be able to say about them and certain
things they don't like.
You can talk all day about black guys
and they're big dicks and I do,
but you can't talk about them like one
fried chicken.
Yeah.
That's negative.
And which is hilarious.
Yes.
We talked about this yesterday.
Chicken has got damn delicious and
fucking wonderful.
What's wrong with being someone who's
into chicken?
I guess maybe they just try.
Maybe.
You know what made me black people are
smart and they just trying to refocus
everybody back on the COC.
So they want all.
They want all stereotypes.
Fried Chicken and watermelon back.
That's probably a very calculated move.
Chess move.
It's checked me from the get go.
Really?
You can't talk about their strawberry
Soda Bitch.
You Racist?
Yeah.
Fuck functions.
We don't enjoy them.
Well,
what else is left?
I heard you have a huge dick word.
Word.
Yeah.
You know,
I was doing a tell show the uh,
will you sit down and you and dave loves
porn
or is that what he was old Dave loves,
which is true,
which is a little bit of that too.
He's a piece of shit.
They used to come into the comedy cellar
with a fucking duffle bag of porn tapes
because I guess he's ocd.
They want to throw him out.
He's like hair,
like you had to pass.
He couldn't bring himself to throw it
out the fuck back.
He needs to be roommates with Yoshi than
Yoshi.
Sent me so much poor and I've watched so
much of it.
I threw out.
I was cleaning out my apartment little
bit and I'm not exaggerating.
Probably a thousand points,
but I just couldn't keep medical.
Yeah,
Jo,
she's ridiculous,
man.
Yoshi had a dude with them once.
I forgot the guy's name,
but he got actually got upset that I
didn't want any.
I go,
come on,
man.
Come on man.
I'm giving these to you man.
We produce these.
I go do,
that's fine,
but thank you very much.
I prefer not to.
I prefer not to take it,
but it was all like keeping stuff.
It was all like,
like pulling.
I don't go for the gay.
I'm not into that.
I don't like to look into a vagina at
all.
What I was going to say about Dave's
show is that when John Holmes was on,
I was like,
his Dick isn't even that big for 21st
century like today.
Like dudes have giant dicks now.
Like you ever seen that?
Like Lexington Steel guy?
Jesus Christ is Dick's like twice the
size of John Holmes.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guys who are getting
bigger.
Yes.
You think it's our cell phones keeping
your pocket?
It's black eyes and they started first
with pagers.
Yeah.
No,
I think it's vibrating it bigger.
I think it's like everything else is
natural selection.
Well Lexington is great.
His Dick works too because johnny is
always like doing like blowing his dick
work.
Half the time was always kind of
halfhearted.
Squeeze it at the base.
I don't get like a rubber snake.
Yeah,
he's holding it tight at the fucking
base.
That trick that we've all pulled the
Lexington both hands in the air.
We were a ginger.
Lynn was on the show and she was talking
about,
uh,
all the different.
I was like,
how come this dude could never get it
up?
And she's like,
cocaine.
All these guys were on coke.
They couldn't get it up because you
watch it and this poor fucking dude is
like,
he just can't get hard.
I guess his name is Jerry Butler.
Oh yeah,
sure.
I know Jerry,
but he,
um,
he,
we totally made fun of him.
And if you hear this cherry,
I totally apologize.
I've never done coke.
I'll imagine it'd be very hard to fuck
while you're on coke.
So if I was making fun of young Dave
show,
it's all just for comedy fellow,
one of the Dukes of hazard,
like he didn't warn guy.
He looked like a sweet handsome kid and
his dick was average.
Like I never liked guys an average day.
Like,
yeah,
like beat it with that fucking thing,
that seven and a quarter.
Fuck yourself.
You know,
I mean I like a fucking,
I like a wrecking ball,
but I've gotten into the,
it's funny like the,
I've gotten into the fucking black and
white porn and I never watched that,
but I started,
I liked the amateur shit of guys just
filming their wires getting,
fuck man,
I really.
Do.
You think they're really filming?
I was fuck,
you can always tell the difference.
I'd say half of them are real and half
of them are actually porn companies,
but there are some that are absolutely
real and you can tell because he's
fucking date in the corner,
you know,
95.
There's awful music playing.
You know what I mean?
There's always some,
uh,
there's something playing in the
background which a porn company could
never license whenever there's music
playing.
If you hear journey playing an
interracial porn,
they probably is a fucking hall moving
because the porn company would never
licensed.
Have a little bit.
Have you been getting into any of the
CAM websites lately?
Have you been doing any of those things?
Never got into camp stuff.
The new ones that are free and you just
there nowadays,
it's nice.
You might really,
really like it.
I'll try it is completely addicted.
Maybe you should not steer a little
jimmy into this whole endeavor.
Maybe ruin his life.
My Free Cams Dot com.
Check it out.
It's just tons and tons and tons of
girls.
Just normal girls.
They have like jobs at applebee's and
stuff like just fucking sitting there
fucking shoving dildos in their ass and
then like if you hate them a little
extra and then they'll go into a private
room.
But my favorite thing is spying on
privates.
You can pay a little extra and spy on
what the private rooms looks.
Looks.
Isn't that ridiculous?
Because that's like,
how is that private key?
You can't buy on the Guy Right now.
No,
you can't see her fucking playing with
Twila.
The fact he gave an awful job like
applebee's.
Well she shouldn't be shoving something
into a squat with that fucking Gig.
Nine to five.
I wonder how many girls are doing that?
Can you.
You can do screen captures,
right?
If you want it.
Last night we,
uh,
entered on a podcast I did with the bone
zone.
We interviewed one of the girls,
really skyped her while she was in the
room and talk to her.
And uh,
so that was,
that's the thing we're going to start
doing now.
More Death Squad is actually talking to
these girls.
There's something about that website.
My Free Cams when you first showed me,
it really kind of freaked me out because
I really had this impression of the
future.
I really had this idea of what this is
really going to be because you click on
this thing and it opens up.
It looks like infinite windows.
It's like,
where are these?
Like these little universes,
like what is this?
And each one of them you click on and
it's a different girl connected to the
Internet doing these little shows and
there's fucking hundreds of them.
And you're looking at this.
I'm like,
this is kind of nuts.
What a weird interface this is.
All these chicks are facing high
themselves and Dildos and,
and you,
you know,
you can give them money and tune in.
It's like,
what the fuck is going on?
Well,
it's amazing.
It's,
it's a great advancement,
but what's going to happen is eventually
privacy will be a thing of it,
and I'm not even saying that's a bad
thing because we're all going to be
locked in on the same mentality.
We're all going to be,
and I'm not even saying it's going to be
a terrible thing.
We're all going to be on the same wave
length mentally.
Eventually the Internet's a great start,
but fast forward 100 years from now,
you're gonna be punished for bad
thoughts as opposed to bad speech or bad
actions.
People gonna know when you think
something because we're already working
on that which Stephen Hawkings,
so we're all going to see each other
sexually.
We're all going to know everything about
each other and eventually it's going to
lose its effect.
The dopamine drip won't work.
We're going to figure out a better way
to get people feel.
You know that feeling you get when
you're fucking crank into your edging.
We're going to find out better ways to
give people that so the sexual loses its
appeal.
Anyway.
This we're in a great time right now if
a pervert because this
will eventually go away.
It's going to get worse,
but how has that been true when there's
so much porn online?
Is that ever going to go with.
How do you think that's going to go with
porn?
Do for you?
Porn makes us.
It turns us on.
It's all these opportunities.
It releases something in the brain when
eventually they figure out get that in a
pill or even through an electrical
impulse or a panel that you won't.
Corn Patch,
get a porn past badge and you'd go and
you'd get a patch and you don't want to
come anymore.
Well,
nobody would take that option,
but you might though because it would
keep you from cheating on your wife.
It will keep you from getting aids.
That would keep you from knocking
somebody up like the benefits for it.
Let's do it.
If I could take one of those,
the amount of hours I sleep better when
I'm jerking off course or if you don't
have keeps me up,
but there's a lot of people that feel
like life connects them to them.
Being direct or them being aroused or
them being,
you know,
in having sex with someone,
they feel like they're not.
They're not alive unless that's
happening.
So if you cut,
if you took a pill that would like do
that,
would it stop your ability to do it
naturally?
You wouldn't be able to.
What'd you just.
You wouldn't want to have sex anymore.
You just want the pill.
You still want sex,
but I think it would take away the drug
part of it.
Eventually we're going to find a way to.
It's almost like with the same thing as
with alcohol and drugs and overeating.
All of that will eventually be fixed
because whatever the brain is doing that
makes you high or makes you feel great,
they'll figure out a way to make
everybody feel like that all the time.
People won't even need to go out and
look for that because we'll all be able
to access that feeling whenever we want
in the next.
What is it?
Quote unquote acceptable way.
Yeah.
We're in a weird period right now when
it comes to things that they give people
when they have mental illnesses or what
they perceive to be mental illnesses or
depression because I have friends that
have taken all sorts of different stuff
and I'm like well how does the doctor
know what to give you?
And it's like,
well they start you on one thing and
we'll see how you react to that and you
know,
if you go to the doctor and say well I
can't get it up anymore and I'm,
I'm really listless throughout the day.
And then they try something else and
they keep switching medications until
they find one that works for you.
Right.
And I'm like,
what?
Like how,
how crazy is that?
Like they've got a,
a bunch of different medications and
they just try them out on you nice and
slow.
Like how much do they vary and how do
you not you sure you got it nailed with
this one and what do we take in here?
What's going on?
I'm up in the air and that stuff.
I think it does work for some people for
sure.
I wouldn't have thought of taking it,
but I'm afraid of my creativity being
fucked with because I probably depressed
all the time and it's like,
it's stupid.
I think I'd rather not be.
So if I can take a pill to kind of
balanced out whatever is wrong in my
stupid brain.
Do you think um,
it is a,
um,
like a pattern thing or do you think
it's a chemical thing?
Like when you feel like you're
depressed,
you do,
you connect it to a certain pattern of
thinking that become self destructive
and you're just real comfortable going
down this pattern?
Or do you connect it to a actual.
Do you feel like man,
there's something wrong with the
chemicals my brain is making?
Or are they even indecipherable?
Are they the same thing?
Do they create each other?
I think,
I think it's a little bit of everything.
Like I think it could be a chemical,
but the chemical combined with just
shitty thinking.
It's comfortable thinking you get used
to like whenever things are good for me,
I start to think like horribly
depressing thoughts.
Like I just,
I don't think I deserve it or whatever
that nonsense is,
but I think it's a combination,
but I know chemical is a part of it
because I feel it like I don't sleep
well and I just feel fucking like thick
and sludgy and fogged all the time and I
fucking hate it.
I guarantee you that's the sleep apnea.
We were talking about this and I told
you that your mouthpiece wasn't the one
that I use.
I use this one by this guy named Ian.
Dr Crowe pen from Tarzana and he's
developed a mouthpiece that it has
almost like a finger that keeps your
tongue from falling back over,
uh,
your,
your wind hole.
That's where.
What were you getting?
No sleep apnea is your fucking fat
tongue.
Likewe collapses while you're lying on
your back and literally covers your air
hole.
It's just a shitty design in the human
face and some of us have it and some
people don't.
Well you have obstructive.
I don't even know if I have obstructive
or a combination of obstructive and
central where central is when your brain
doesn't send the signal.
Like I think that's what it's called.
Like when I've,
because I've woken up at times and just
got.
You haven't breathed like breathing.
You're not like not I'm trying to
breathe,
but I have not attempted a breath and I
know I'll miss a couple of cycles and I
wake up panicking and uh,
I think I might have part of that too
because the mouthpiece I have I sleep a
little better with.
It does help.
But I don't know if it's totally an
obstructive apnea thing.
I actually woke the guy up on the plane
coming back from Brazil.
Uh,
yeah.
I remember just being horrible Joe.
I remember like being on a plane next to
you and just being like,
what the fuck?
That's not normal.
But now even like it was that bad.
But no,
my,
I snored real bad,
real bad.
But what I'm saying is I saw a guy
having sleep apnea and I,
I,
it was hidden.
He was a big guy and so I went to the
flight attendant and I'm like,
this guy goes for like these stretches
where he's not breathing,
right?
Like it was a long stretch.
There were like 20,
25 seconds with no breathing and he see
him struggle and struggle and then.
And then he would close it up again and
I was like,
wow,
that guy is going to die.
Like you can't keep doing that.
Like that's real bad sleep apnea.
I didn't know what it looked like to
watch someone like choke and gasp for
air and then then like his chest wasn't
moving.
He was like,
like what?
Little wiggles with his chest,
but no breathing and then all sudden
look like big swallowing and gasping.
So this guy's getting no sleep.
If he sleeps like this every night he
gets no fucking sleep.
So I'm like,
dude,
you can get a heart attack from this for
real.
This is,
you need to do something about this
Llama Basil.
It's hard for me to fall asleep.
It's not anything.
It's hard for me to stay asleep like
I've had to get up and paid because
I've,
I've had had to go to the bathroom and
then somebody said that that's sometimes
your mind wakes you up thinking that
like you're not going to breathe so it
wakes you up to piss because that will
get you up.
It's a really weird signalling.
Your body will send,
like,
it'll make you feel.
You have to Piss.
That's worried about your control.
Yeah.
Which shows you like our priorities are
like,
I can't,
I can't breathe on my own,
but I have to piss all.
Jump up and I'll take a,
you see,
this guy didn't say woke him up.
I woke him up.
He woke up rather when he saw the,
uh,
the flight attendant and me like
watching him maybe like sense that we
were.
Maybe it wasn't sleeping anyway because
he was snoring so loud.
But um,
he,
uh,
he had no idea.
He had no idea when I was told that I
had sleep apnea,
you know,
when I went to way,
uh,
I had,
you know,
I knew that I had snored,
but when I went to an actual place or
they monitor,
like when you go to sleep,
right to do that with you?
Yeah.
But I get to take home and they say I
definitely had not the worst apnea,
but the next 100.
Oh my God.
Just like what are the worst.
I wouldn't have fallen asleep in a place
like that where you able to fall asleep.
It was real hard for a different level.
You're covered with these fucking
electronics can do that.
It was really hard,
but I was so tired.
I made sure that I got.
I showed up.
They're really tired.
But man,
I just smoked first.
No,
no,
just,
just went.
Oh,
okay.
Because I don't smoke before I go to
sleep usually.
No,
no.
I spoke before.
I write small before I do Jujitsu.
Oh Wow.
So that.
I'm very surprised here.
Yeah.
No,
that's the best way to do Jiu Jitsu
because you're more relaxed,
more focused.
They know this,
first of all,
the type of pot that I smoke is a,
there's two types of two different types
of pot.
One is called Endeca and one's called
Sativa and Indica is the stuff that
people get that makes you like,
it's almost like a narcotic.
It's like you could collapse into the
couch.
It's just like more of like a sedative,
more of like a,
it makes you kind of feel like just at
ease,
chill and relaxed.
And it's great for like pain.
It's great for sex.
But Sativa is the stuff that I liked and
that's more speedy.
It's more um,
sort of,
um,
it feels like it accelerates your
thinking and makes you,
it makes you think about crazy shit.
Like the best thing for me is sativa and
like a Carl Sagan documentary,
you know,
you just go,
what the fuck?
And you listened to the Carl Sagan
explaining the universe and it's just
like,
it's,
you know,
it's the perfect pot for thinking.
He wrote a community,
a communion with communion and I was
contacted,
Jodie foster.
He wrote,
yeah,
that was a great fucking moving.
That was,
to this day,
still holds up,
watched it the other day.
It's one of those things where you're
like,
oh yeah,
that's probably how it would actually
happen when she's going through and the
fucking warm haul.
It all kind of feels right.
It doesn't feel cheesy or Hokey at all.
It's look system.
I mean,
we were talking about this yesterday.
I had the guy from ancient aliens on and
uh,
we were talking about,
the possibilities of a Ufo was like
that,
like what the they had in contact.
That doesn't seem outside the realm of
what we're capable of and 30 years or 50
years or 100 years.
I mean,
if you asked me could we come up?
Something like that.
If we lived
a thousand years,
I'd be like,
fucking,
of course we could.
You have.
I interviewed Bernie,
I think.
Wait,
no,
Ray Kurzwell.
No.
I know.
We had them on want and he's kind of a
dry guy,
but he's a real genius.
And he talks about how technology is
advancing exponentially.
Like we're doubling our knowledge and
doubling and doubling or knowledge and
he thinks there's going be a point of
singularity,
but we just know everything as it
happened.
Where are we will catch up because the
way technology age,
our brain,
like once we can incorporate something
like Google,
you'll just think of something and know
it.
You won't need to Google it.
You'll.
He was a genius and I think his time
frame is off because he thinks that in
40 years we're going to have singularity
and I think he thinks that because he
wants to stay alive,
but he talks about immortality and
uploading.
Once we understand how the electrical
impulses can be uploaded to a hard
drive.
He's a fascinating guy.
Yeah.
I've read a bunch of stuff.
Oh,
you have?
Okay.
I'm explaining to them,
you know,
I'd love that document.
It's good to.
For people to hear that documentary,
the transcendent man.
Yeah.
That's a fucking amazing documentary.
Really,
really interesting.
It was really interesting to see the
different points of view.
The people who are really optimistic
about intelligence that is artificially
created and people who are terrified of
it,
but some of those guys that were like,
you don't understand.
Like if this happens,
like the one guy that was calling it an
artilect who was the English guy who's
talked about our telex.
I don't know.
I don't know if I saw this special.
I've just.
I've just read some of the stuff that
will.
They had a bunch of different people
that are experts on this idea of
artificial intelligence becoming
sentient and one of them was like,
fucking,
we're going to get wiped out.
One of them was like,
this guy's like all terminator doom and
gloom.
Like we don't even know what's going to
happen.
And with the real worry is that if they
fuck around and like program emotions
and jealousy and rage into a computer
thinking that they have to do this in
order to really truly replicate a human
being instead of replicating someone
completely creepy with no emotions.
I mean,
if they're going to make an artificial
person,
wouldn't they make an artificial person
that has human characteristics so it
would blend in.
So then what if that fucking thing is,
this artificial computer can actually
make a better artificial computer that a
human can make and then it just
exponentially increases in like over a
period of like zero time.
They've created way better human beings
than we could've ever created.
And that's the singularity.
And then the shit really hits the fan.
Well,
it wouldn't surprise me if it happens
eventually because I mean again,
it's all chemical reactions,
anger,
rage,
jealousy one,
and it's all unique.
Could probably break it down to ones and
Zeros.
So once they figured that out in the
computer and they can map our DNA,
that stuff will definitely be a part of
it.
It's going to be a weird thing that
they're going to have to discuss.
Should we create like these crazy fake
people that never get angry.
Maybe that's the future
Birdie did artificial intelligence,
like Siri,
it's like meeting series,
like a girl he met at a coffee shop
briefly and then in like 10 or 15 years
we're going to actually see her in a
different form,
you know,
a little older.
And then one day we're gonna be fucking
Siri if you think about it.
She's,
she's the star of artificial
intelligence.
I Hate Siri.
I fucking hate it.
I'd still worst I try to.
I try to talk with it and just go back.
Donk,
donk,
donk.
It just fucking mocked me.
I can never get Siri work.
Yeah,
I'm
not a fan of it.
I,
you know,
I forgot about it and I started using it
again and it was like,
oh yeah,
this is totally helpful.
I liked the call feature can say called
Norton,
calling north reading text messages when
you're driving.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I don't do that.
I Made Sam father listen to me fucking
dirty talk somebody through Syria.
I was afraid to do it,
so I was driving and dirty talking to
chicken.
It actually came out pretty good,
but it was weird.
They have a guy here that you know,
you have to correct it because it's
saying it wrong or whatever.
That's hilarious.
Driving dirty,
talking in a text through Siri.
It seems like that's an extra activity
of the future.
It's hard.
It's a hard drug to break,
man.
The fucking the dirty talk to texting
the fucking that whole keep it going and
have a bunch of those little windows
open and just go to it and go to it and
go to it.
It's so hard to fucking break that.
It's really difficult.
She just enjoy the banter puck.
I love it.
I love it more than actually fucking
really.
What is it about just the excitement of
knowing someone's into you and they
respond to you and it just gets kind of
freaky and then you're like,
how far is this going to go and Holy
Shit.
Which she went with it and I can't
believe she's going to put it in my ass.
What?
Oh my God.
And her saying that to me in my ass.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah,
no her saying that to you straight me
right now is my Dick,
you know,
like whoa.
I liked the idea of it,
but I liked the high of it.
Um,
it fucking is the end of it.
It's like going to sleep after you've
been drinking.
You want to just keep the rush going,
keep the high going and once you fucking
comments over once you blow your load.
I've actually had escorts were,
I haven't blown a load because they
weren't the perfect one and I waited
till later that night.
Just completed diction man.
Have you had him Roy before Jimmy?
No,
I got a little bit of a Roy.
Not too bad.
Um,
which is a shame because my ex wanted to
fuck me with the strap on and I would
have let her,
but I will just flow really well without
a doubt.
So you still have a pretty butthole
then?
Like you don't have any fucking war
damage?
No,
it's nice.
It's actually not bad at all.
I really had almost nothing in my ass.
A lot of tongues because it's very
hairless.
Very rarely has any odor.
My ass is phenomenal.
When it comes to that shit with odor,
I very rarely is it gold bond.
I don't sweat it.
How many times have you had a girl use a
strap on on?
You know,
I've had a couple of tribe.
My ex girlfriend tried,
she was a trooper,
but I would always go like,
ah,
and I got maybe the helmet and I could
never get more than that.
I felt like I had to shell when the
girls doing that,
is she doing it because it turns her on
or she's doing that because like,
it's fun.
Like what,
what is she doing?
Is She just made she sticking something
inside you that she can't even feel.
But she's feeling the power of it.
So sure.
It's like to somebody like when you
spank somebody,
it turns you on,
but it doesn't turn you on because
there's a sensation on your hand.
It's the fucking sound.
It's the,
it's the representation.
Oh,
you spank a girl.
It's all that stuff.
The domination of it.
That's how I think he feels when she's
fucking you with a strap on.
Whoa.
Um,
and I never actually,
I wish I could do it.
I'm a fucking dirt bag.
I would love it,
but I can't get through it.
I haven't tried it alone.
Time.
It's the female version of the bank
then?
I think so,
yeah.
I mean I like a woman can dominate me,
but properly not fucking cornball,
you know,
get on your knees.
Slave.
There are their hack and there's all,
most of them are hacks.
But a girl who knows not to wear
deodorant and just put her fucking
armpit over my face.
That's a chick that can fucking own me.
You date,
like a lot of foreign women rush.
I've had Indian Pussy.
I don't talk about it like food.
So he said it.
Got To link any food.
I don't like Canadian plus either.
No,
I don't.
It's the fucking,
as far as Canada is an okay country.
But I've every Canadian pussy I've ever
gotten a hold of fucking reeked.
I've never had a Canadian pussy that I
didn't have to fucking back off.
I wonder,
is it like maple syrup or what is just
an odd sour fucking.
I don't know what it is and he's a
fucking 12 hour drive or it's the
fucking that will water or there's
something chemically different about
them.
I just don't enjoy it.
Something in their climate or something.
Maybe some of the hottest girls on the
planet.
They're from Canada.
They are lovely.
But you know,
I got cockies not too long ago by some
Canadian stripper.
So do you like you hold a grudge for all
Canadians because this one girl,
not my role.
Anti Canadian Pussy.
That's been a few girls.
Believe me,
I,
I tried the theory.
I never just go with one bad one because
it could have been period.
Like I don't like armpits.
If a girl has a period period,
pitzer fucking humanist girls.
You are an expert in how girls armpits
smell differently during their period
with girlfriends.
At least I can tell.
Once you know somebody chemically,
man,
you can tell by their scent.
Like we did a contest in Cleveland and I
got most of them right.
But you can tell if it's an annuity,
fucking smell.
She's probably on a rag in.
Her body's just expelling everything.
That shit was amazing.
It's just depends on your diet though.
A part of it does.
Yeah.
But if you have a consistency and the
fucking something about that fucking
smell it.
But again,
it can't be that fucking oniony pit
odor.
But if you have a good chemistry with
somebody,
there's something about that that makes
me crazy.
Men.
And do you like bio or do you like Geo
Obo?
But it puts.
I liked the mouth to be clean.
I want her mouth the face clean.
Um,
I don't want to fuck it.
He just to smell waxy.
I don't want her belly button.
This stink.
The feet can smell a little bit.
Honest to God.
I liked that a little bit and a little
bit of a fucking little sweaty and the
ass can smell a little bit and the pussy
a little bit.
As long as it's not fucking checklist,
I swear to God.
Deniro face on where you go to this
checklist.
Okay,
good.
I had the.
ASCE has a certain level,
it can go to a little bit of a fucking
lie yourself a little bit.
Just a little bit.
The as what is the particular smile
that's acceptable?
Is there a level?
It's like they say about pornography.
I don't know what A.
I can't describe it.
I know what I see it.
That's the way it is with an asshole.
It's like I,
I.
It has a slight asshole smell to it.
Like a must.
It's fun.
It's nice.
What is that all law about obscenity.
How do you define upset?
And He that was the.
That's the question that a lot of
trials,
right?
Well,
community standards and this is why it's
in trouble and by the way,
I would love to know where all like the
fucking libertarian political
organizations where when Max hardcore
went to jail for four years because they
nailed him when he,
when he mailed stuff to fucking Tampa
because Florida stinkers type of stuff
and they trapped them and got them on
some obscene community standards thing,
but when we wizard but he's sticking up
for Max hardcore.
This guy did for years for adult
pornography.
It's fucking adults.
There was no children involved.
It seems really strange that you could
have something that is not illegal.
That is obviously it's marketable,
I mean,
whether or not it's healthy to watch
that kind of shit.
It's obviously people are watching it
and there is always that argument that
certain types of depravity keeps people
from committing things in the real life
that they can get through it in some
sort of a fantasy form and it keeps them
from being a creep or,
uh,
a violent person in their real life.
And if some of the signs of fucking
waiver man and what,
where do you cross the line?
Where do you decide that this is
something that this guy needs to get
locked in a cage for because you don't
agree with the whole country is full of
shit when it comes to free speech and
free thought because all of us,
and I mean,
well I shouldn't say all ideologies,
liberal and conservative,
haven't asked her as like,
you're free to say this and do this as
long as you.
And,
and for the liberals it's what they call
hate speech and anything that's racial
or homophobia.
And for the conservatives,
it's,
hey,
don't fuck with God and country,
but both sides are equally phony when it
comes to like,
when's the last time,
uh,
like a feminist stuck up for a guy who
said something about women that was
unpleasant because he has the right to
say it never.
Like,
where were all these people?
When Tracy Morgan said what he said,
why didn't nobody who didn't like him
stick up for all countries for it's just
like they don't have that much
resources.
So it's not like they can jump into the
fray for any little situation.
They don't have that much time when
you're running some sort of an
organization that's looking for violence
against women or anything,
but you don't have,
you have to look at concentrate only on
that.
I,
I don't fault them for going after,
you know,
or not going after cases where guys like
Tracy Morgan got busted or now they only
have a certain amount of things they
want to concentrate on.
But no,
I mean I fault them for going after him
because he was like,
why don't like when people went after
him,
why didn't they just stick up for them
and go,
we don't like what he said,
but he's got the right to say it.
There should be no penalty for it.
That's what I mean.
And none of these groups,
which would take them two seconds to put
out that fucking memo,
but glad has never done it.
None of them have done it.
No,
they no,
they don't devote any resources to
helping anybody else out there develop
resources to pushing their ideology and
their ideology is that this guy needs to
be punished because if he's punished and
it cost him a lot of money,
then people are going to stop thinking
like that.
You're gonna stop expressing themselves
like that,
which I can see their point it up to a
certain point where you got to realize,
is it okay?
Where does this,
where does this,
where's this line happened?
Is it okay for Denzel Washington to play
a murderer and a gangster and a movie?
It is,
right.
Okay.
Why is it not okay for Tracy Morgan to
portray a guy who's pretending that he
would stab
his son if he was gay?
Because he's not telling the truth.
He's,
he's,
he's obviously doing a character that is
like completely over the top and says
ridiculous shit all the time.
That his.
That's his shtick.
Oh,
by the way,
I was incorrect when I apologize.
You just straighten me out.
When I said the women's groups,
I should have said the gay groups.
I was thinking that it was.
Tracy said something that was anti
woman.
I forgot that it was that.
I actually forgot what I just went.
Remember the conflict?
I'm saying why doesn't the group was
saying that gay dudes are women.
Um,
so all the great ones are.
I mean,
let's be honest,
who hasn't seen a transexual and fall in
love with them on.
It's an open society folks.
Yeah.
I think Tracy got to.
People have to understand that it was
people that want to see him do that.
You might not like it,
but it's like dice.
I'd love dice.
I've always loved dice.
I want to see him go fucking bananas.
It's a form of entertainment and if he
does it about Italians,
which I am,
I will.
I will laugh.
I will laugh along with it because I
know,
you know,
if he's making fun of us,
it's mostly true shit,
you know,
but for whatever reason,
some people want to pretend that you
know,
some of his ridiculous over the top.
Stereotypes aren't funny.
It's hilarious character.
This character will fucking.
I'd love it.
It's great entertainment.
I swallow my load yet chew it takes that
seriously.
Why would you be angry?
This guy?
Why?
I mean it's.
This is just a.
This is entertainment.
It's comedy and it's a.
it's a valid form of comedy and this is
where it gets weird.
It's like when you,
when a guys creating art and believe it
or not,
Tracy Morgan's creating fucking art.
When he gets on stage and he does stand
up,
he's not trying to fucking piss people
off.
He's just going with.
This is one of the.
This is one of the styles of comedy.
You say completely outrageous shit.
We all know guys who would sit like
Brian Holtzman is one of my perfect
examples.
Brian,
he did a joke about Susan Smith after,
after,
uh,
Susan Smith got caught drowning.
He goes on stage like two days later and
he goes,
this Susan Smith case,
she'd drawn a kids.
Yeah,
I heard those were bad kids.
I heard they sat that close to the TV.
They always spelt the fucking milk.
They don't put away that blocks.
Those kids will not be met.
And we were laughing and gasping the
whole audience.
It was a combination of laughs and
gasps.
And that's a valid piece of art.
That's a valid piece of art.
He doesn't really mean that he isn't.
If he had to choose,
he would say yes,
please go back in time and stop her
before she tells her children he's a
character.
He's playing a crazy accentuated
He gets into a zone and he does this,
this thing onstage and he says like,
really offensive shit and it's fucking
funny and I enjoy it.
It's art or even when you're just being
yourself and exploring a ridiculous sap,
but we never.
People never stick up for that,
and the same people that would defend
maple thorp or any other form of art
piss Christ and a jar are the same.
There's the same mentality that will
attack tracy or that will attack a,
um,
uh,
I missed what he said,
or Michael.
Richard.
It's a fraudulent stance and every side
does it.
It drives me fucking crazy.
I think there's,
yeah.
Is people have this idea.
A lot of people I should say have this
idea that if you don't agree with them,
you're wrong and your,
your,
uh,
if you're,
you're against them.
You don't.
It's not like you can enjoy different
things or have different ideas about
different standards of living and what
you shouldn't,
shouldn't be able to do.
No,
it's not that.
It's.
If you don't agree you're wrong and
people have to understand that different
people like different shit.
Right?
And you can't force someone to not like
porn.
You can't force someone to say you're
not gay.
You know,
you cannot be gay.
We're not.
You can't do that.
It doesn't work.
Like you have to let people do whatever
the fuck they want to do and then you
just got to kind of accept that that's
them.
And I wish a lot of these phony artists,
like I say,
following meaning singers,
I think that they're hit by attacking
Christianity.
Like I have no profit attack.
Christianity finally.
Sure it's right there,
but it's like none of them address
Islam.
None of them addressed the fact that
they're afraid to attack is.
And that's what drives me crazy because
it's this fucking fake edge.
It's the,
it's this fucking fake.
I'm being dangerous.
But it's really,
they're looking both ways before they
cross the street and they're acting like
they just bolted out the front door and
it fucking drives me.
It drives me nuts.
Yeah,
it's the,
there's a certain amount of posturing
that people,
uh,
people get into when they start talking
about certain political issues and
certain things,
certain ideologies.
And it gets to that gross place where
people just start clapping and you can
tell they're disingenuous and it just,
there were milking off this thing for
their own ego.
They're milking off this reality for
their own ego instead of just sort of
trying to,
you know,
trying to look at the big picture
because the big.
I mean you're absolutely right.
Why doesn't anybody want to make fun of
Islam?
I'll tell you why.
Because they'll fucking kill you.
Yeah.
Like they took shit to an entirely
different place.
And so anybody who wants to pretend to
be edgy,
it doesn't involve going that far.
I mock them,
but I mean I can,
I'm careful where I put the joe come out
an idiot,
you know?
I mean I'm not crazy though.
You right now just admitted to self
censorship for the same thing.
You just find it more reasonable because
you say that your take on it as well.
You know,
I'll take it back a little bit.
as far as I'm sure,
but you are clearly saying that you
wouldn't say what you'd normally would
want to say because they're dangerous.
Sure.
But I will say that that's why I'm not
saying it isn't that amazing.
It's a terrifying thing in 2012 that we
still have a faction of our world that
you have to literally can't draw their
guy,
but I also won't say other things
onstage for feeling like,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
niggers a rough word to pull out.
You better have a reason.
Yes.
For you say that on stage.
You can't just go out and.
I would never say it in anger at
somebody,
but it's like every.
Everything has lines and stuff and
reasons I don't say it and I do self
center and I think we all do as comics
you,
you have to.
We're not crazy,
but I never want people to panelize when
they don't.
That's the difference.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's really crazy when you get to like
these
guys that were American Muslim converts
that were publicly online calling for
the death of Matt stone and Trey Parker
for doing unc.
My drawing of Mohamad no matter which
side of it,
you'd probably not even allowed to do
that if I said that,
that that's probably like,
hey,
some sort of a thing for Bloomberg was
sell on the money too because when they
found that car bomb in time square,
Mike Bloomberg right on it,
he comes out.
He goes,
well,
let's not jump to conclusions.
How do you know it's not somebody
against healthcare be and because we
live in America in 2011 dummy and we
know it's somebody from Islam we know
and we will.
Right?
It's a weird thing that that's going on
right now.
It's a weird thing when you watch like,
um,
any of the videos,
videos of like the real extremists in
different parts of the world and see
women wearing burkas and you realize
this is all going on in the age of the
Internet.
You know,
the whole world.
It's like this is not,
it's not worked out yet.
This is,
this is clearly not worked out yet.
Well,
it's changing.
I mean,
and we think it's changing and he's
like,
well,
facebook for Christ sake.
I mean,
look at the Egypt,
they overthrew the government and what
did they do?
They like the Muslim Brotherhood wants
Sharia law.
Like it kind of feels like a circle.
Yeah,
that seems crazy.
It's like,
all right guys,
really say what you're going to do.
I just,
I got to stand against you when you want
to kill people for drawing teddy bears,
because that's what the Muhammad thing
was,
right?
He was in a teddy bear suit.
I.
Come on,
man.
Really?
You can't even draw a teddy bear irony.
Kind of fucking religion is.
You guys aren't.
You don't have enough love going on.
The only way you would have this idea in
your head that you should die if you
draw a fucking teddy bear is if you need
a hug.
Man.
I didn't draw my eyes with your bond.
It just for the record.
I did not draw that picture.
Photo photo.
It's not depiction.
Nobody thinks that was Mohammed.
It's Mas.
Yeah.
Even the Islams wouldn't kill you too
stupid.
They're probably just fucking Islamic
terrorists.
Yeah,
though.
Let's go see how great would it be if we
got killed,
but not just to kind of follow.
I'm kidding.
Jesus.
There you will be performing with him
tonight.
I'll.
Are you really?
Yeah.
We're doing a show with him at the Ice
House.
Am I said Hi.
Oh No,
no monster.
Probably forever.
He's a good guy.
I like him a lot.
He's an awesome guy.
He's like enormous in the Persian
community.
Right?
Isn't he?
Like,
he performed a superstar.
I think he performs in Dubai and all
these like places that I probably
couldn't survive.
Meaning just because not survive
physically,
but just the language would be too
strong.
He can go overseas and do these gigs and
uh,
yeah,
he's huge in that community.
Yeah,
you could get in trouble.
It was it.
How sparks that was saying that,
uh,
he almost got arrested in Dubai.
Was it a house party?
She had that whole story where.
Yeah.
That was how right I was for some
reason.
I confused that store with him and
someone else.
I don't know why,
but yeah,
he,
uh,
probably Bert Kreischer.
No,
I.
Who Do I always confuse it with?
Hm.
I don't remember now.
But Anyway,
point is it's like,
it's real tricky
because you can get locked in jail if
you say the wrong thing.
The wrong thing in the wrong country is
scary.
That's why I don't go overseas.
I mean people will say,
well do you want to perform and Dubai.
I'm like,
I couldn't because they're pretty.
They're pretty liberal in comparison,
but they don't,
you know.
I mean,
come on man.
It's a fucking.
That's not exactly like performing at
Montreal while sparks.
It was him already.
If this is going to say it's either
Eddie for you.
What's the first shit?
I bet if we were on twitter right now we
would know,
but I want to say it's Eddie now.
I want to say it's how sparks you think.
Sorry.
I think Eddie,
if it had another story that was
similar,
but I don't think it was the one that
we're thinking of where he was.
I got to,
he had a show and he did something and a
Dubai and something.
Oh,
right.
No,
I think,
um,
I think you're right.
I think it was how sparse,
but all he said was mature,
which I mean,
you know,
like a French,
the French name for Mr Israel.
That's what he said,
like he called the Guy Mature,
whatever the hell his name is and he
had.
But the guy's real name was like,
he's like a chic.
So it's like he's like,
you know,
I don't know what you'd say,
but there's some sort of very ominous
distinction that you have to give them,
you know what I mean?
Whatever it is,
you know,
his royal highness,
you have to say something like that.
You can't say mature.
So when he said that they,
they wanted to arrest him.
Fuck that.
That's it.
And that's all
stars are always offered to go to Dubai
for like tons of money just for a week,
just go to Dubai for a week and be like
a princess slave or something like that.
And then like,
like,
like your,
your salaries,
you know,
in one fucking week
did now,
did the sheik want them arrested?
Yeah.
Oh No,
no,
no.
She didn't want them arrested at all and
that's why he got away with it because
the royal family was taking photos with
them after the show and uh,
the police,
when the police show up,
they have like,
it's like a religious police.
Right.
And when the police showed up,
they released him because they said that
it was one guy's idea to arrest him and
that guy was wrong because if the royal
family had seen the show and he had said
something,
sack religious,
he would,
you know,
they would not be wanting to take
pictures with him.
Right.
So based on the fact that this,
that hal didn't listen to them because
they were saying like,
you wait here for the royal police or
the whatever the fuck the police was
called.
And Hal just went outside the door and
started taking photos with everybody,
including the royal family.
And that's what saved them.
That the royal family thought it was
funny because otherwise he was going to
be going to jail on one person's
recommendation.
That's how I remember the story,
right.
It was that.
How was my guy enough to me to say,
there's no way I could do a fucking show
there.
That's why I don't go because it scares
me because you don't know all the rules.
Like I know in America I'm not going to
get arrested on stage.
I know that.
I mean,
again,
as long as you're not calling for the
place to be fucking bombed or a murder
to take place,
just doing my stupid act.
I'm never going to go to jail.
Not here.
Not here in Canada.
You get in trouble though.
They had that fucking human rights
commission that goes after people.
For the guy who had the comic,
who made fun of the lesbians and the
audience who are talking and uh,
this stupid human rights commission
takes aside to the fucking hecklers.
So crazy guys.
Well,
what they're saying is that what he was
doing was like,
hate speech and that should be forbidden
and he shouldn't be able to do that for
the stage.
But you know,
you don't understand if you're.
First of all,
we're,
we're talking about standup comedy,
which is an art form,
and we've already established that
that's a fucking viable form of that art
form,
the Ultra Offensive Don rickles style.
It's always existed.
It's fucking hilarious when you watch a
guy get dressed down in front of all
these people because he says something,
it's.
It's a part of the show,
so when you start talking in a comedy,
show your you fucking give up all rights
to be offended.
Okay,
because you're now part of the show and
we've got to do whatever the fuck we
have to do to salvage this show for
everyone else in the room.
There's 300 other people,
but because one asshole wants to get
drunk and yellow and then you go after
him or her who had whatever it is,
and then you're in trouble because of
something harsh to.
You said to them,
they became a part of the show.
When you're a part of the show,
I am adlibbing.
I can't guarantee it's going to work.
I can't guarantee I'm not going to go
over the top.
I can't guarantee.
I'm not going to say something that
really was kind of fucked up,
but I can guarantee the only reason I'm
talking to you because you fucked up the
cell phone.
You don't.
He writes this selfishness that inspired
them to talk is the same selfishness
that makes them feel they should be
vindicated.
Yes.
And make them feel self righteously
angry.
It's almost like once you know somebody
selfish Twat,
which they are,
when they heckle,
you know that going into it,
they're gonna usually get upset because
the,
the they,
the selfish people that self centered.
People like this fucking lady that's
suing this 11 year old kid for hitting
her in the face with a baseball standing
near where the kids are throwing
baseballs.
She got hit in the face by a baseball
and she's suing this kid for half a
million dollars.
What kind of a fucking crazy asshole
Susan?
Eleven year old kid for throwing a
baseball and I'll tell you,
this is what's also repulsive is that
happened in Jersey and of course the
little league is not supporting them at
all.
That it's a matter between the dose cock
suckers fucking walked right away from
this guy because they weren't named in
the litigation.
So.
So the selfishness is,
is everywhere.
Everybody is fucking self obsessed and
it comes from the people.
That's why people,
their insurance companies rape us.
That's why they rape us because we're
all fucking selfish.
People sue and then the doctors have to
pay a higher insurance.
They charge you more.
It's like we.
But we started fucking each other on the
ground level.
But there's that thing.
It's like,
I totally agree with that.
Just way too many people that look at
lawsuits as the lottery.
I mean we've all seen videos of people
faking falling down when they have those
hidden security cameras and they're like
slip on purpose.
You see them like look around and fall
and then they show them the video and
they fucking bust them.
But there are people that really do
legitimately fucking hurt themselves
because of someone's negligence.
Absolutely.
If your mom is walking and some asshole,
you know,
mop the floor and didn't tell anybody
that it was still wet and didn't put up.
One of those little things,
so everybody chills out a little danger
little thing and you fall and break your
fucking hip.
You shouldn't be.
You shouldn't have to pay for that.
Somebody fucked up.
My grandmother got hurt in a bank
parking lot like that.
She slipped and she hurt herself and I
think she only got a few grand,
like they kind of fucked around the
settlement.
She didn't get anything.
She was older,
hip fucked up.
I taste.
See both sides of it.
I definitely see that some people get
fucked over and buy things that other
people were negligent about.
You know,
that they should have taken
responsibility to make sure that their
customers were safe.
I see that too,
but they also say that there's a lot of
people that look at any opportunity to
sue someone like it's the lottery.
Legitimate lawsuit.
I'm not talking about those because
there are plenty of times where you
should be able to see the doctor for
malpractice sows you up and he leaves
something in you that's grounds for a
lawsuit for sure.
If he makes it critical error,
should you be able to sue,
like should a guy be able to sue,
say if you're given a guy a massage and
that guy wants you to jerk them off?
No.
Um,
I think he should actually be able to
sue you for not offering to that.
Fuck.
It makes me.
These guys are selling Travolta for 2
million.
Here's what,
here's what annoys me is that the guy
said he liked Travolta,
grabbed for his scrotum,
and then he said like a few minutes
later,
trouble.
Whoa,
whoa.
A fucking housing later,
man.
If he said,
if he said Travolta,
grabbed my scrotum and I drop the oil
and fucking ran out the door,
that's the guy.
That to me is a legitimate beef.
But what happened was he kept you going
to tell me as a mature,
you don't read that fucking body
language.
Every time I pushed my ass hole up in
the air,
fucking chick massage him.
He knows exactly what I want.
Every time,
every time she creeps up my thigh and I
go,
she knows I'm saying fucking goal for my
balls.
It's an unwritten.
It,
it's,
you're going into it with plausible
deniability from both people,
but the mature and the zoos always
knows.
The therapist always knows when you want
something extra,
they feel it.
They the fucking body.
So do you think that the majority of
guys that he propositions,
do you think,
what do you think his batting ratio is?
I'm,
I'm going to guess Travolta if I had,
if any of it's true,
I will speculate that he's probably
batting 800 or 7:50.
He's got fucking,
he probably makes ty cobb but like a
fucking rank amateur because a guy in
that position,
you know,
first of all he's not used to hearing.
No.
And he has enough money to just keep
throwing money at you.
Sometimes I've,
I've upped the ante.
I've upped the ante with $150 massage.
Like come on,
I'll be really generous.
And then not like email when you got
them with the other girls do that.
Gotcha.
Like in my hand,
I'm like,
fucking got ya.
I know when they ask a certain question,
I'll let you know that you got them on
that question because they wouldn't
inquire if they weren't interested.
Like um,
one girl told me she was massaging me
and I was like,
you know,
cause she's like,
girls do this.
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
I'll take good care of them.
And,
and she's like,
I would never do that.
She's like,
well,
how much do you give them real?
I fucking soul.
Got You.
I saw,
got you.
And I did for 300.
She let me jerk off.
I rubbed her ass on the bed and I jerked
off on the floor.
So she gets,
she makes deals,
like,
you can do this,
but you can't do that.
Yeah.
And you kind of like,
you have a certain.
Again,
there's a certain lingo
you go with,
you don't just go,
I'll give you this because that makes
them feel like a prostitute and they're
really not prostitutes.
It just girls making a snap judgment
that you're okay and fuck it.
I'll play with them and make a little
extra.
Right.
And it's,
in a way,
it's kind of safe.
Suddenly you're going to do anything
crazy or in a massage parlor.
Well,
Neil,
it's usually my house.
I rarely bring them to your house.
I'll do.
I can't pull that off in a fucking spa.
They won't go near your cock and a spa.
They mummy wrapped.
I hate that.
Whenever they lift my thigh in the
therapeutic fashion and wrapped the
towel,
I'm like,
oh,
what if you're having them come to your
house and massage you,
man.
That's how many of those girls are doing
the hand release.
I'd say I've had maybe a 60 to 70 or 65
percent of batting average,
but a lot of them I haven't tried it on
because I know they want.
When they walk in the door,
a lot of times you can tell by the
attitude the vide,
the body language that they're not
gonna.
Do that so easy job for a girl man.
And do you ever go to that website,
like the yelp page for that,
a happy endings or something like that?
I never knew it existed.
There's a page that just breaks down
every single like massage parlor and
girls that are like in papers and stuff.
Every town.
I think it's happy endings.
It's wonderful.
No,
I've never done that,
but I certainly will.
It's pretty legit.
I think I feel okay.
I feel much different about it knowing
that you actually get these girls to go
to your house because I would assume
that most girls when they go to guy's
houses have to be thinking it was a very
high possibility.
This guy might whip his dick out.
Yeah.
That a lot of times they know.
It depends on how if they go there
because of a recommendation,
sometimes I'm like,
well,
she knows that I go with someone to
massage me and I never do anything with
her,
so she feels comfortable.
You read the thing going in and that's.
Those therapists don't tell me you
didn't know.
Trolls is body language and you could
have stopped and walked out whenever you
want it to.
So while I do believe their account,
I don't believe any of them deserve any
money.
I feel bad for Travolta.
I mean,
it's got to be tortured to be,
to be that guy and want to do some
things that you just can't fucking do,
to want to come out and go,
yeah,
I did it.
So what that means Sonia,
for millions of dollars.
Get the fuck out of here.
Well,
his whole situation is so we're.
Because look,
if it's all not true,
then it's like,
what is this some crazy conspiracy
against this guy?
Like what's going on is this.
I mean,
if it's not true,
it's,
it's terrible and he's being persecuted
and if it is true,
so don't fucking massage them.
You know,
it's up.
Now the cat's out of the bag.
If John Travolta calls you up and it's
2:00
in the afternoon on a Saturday and you
got to go to his hotel to massage,
I assume you have to suck his dick or
he's going to want to suck yours.
We know,
okay,
now we know.
Can we just leave it alone?
Like why do we have to beat it into the
ground?
Why does someone have to get sued now?
You know,
don't go to Johnson.
Did you know like some guys are saying,
well,
you already had a reputation.
Well then why the fuck did you go?
Did you go maybe their job,
maybe the job.
The boss said,
listen,
you've got to take this one for the
team.
Yeah,
but I think you can tell your boss like,
look,
he was opening his asshole the last time
you gotta you gotta set the rules right
away.
Mr Travolta.
This is not going to get sexual,
which to him must be like
the ultimate turn on to eventually think
of his dick in your mouth after you
saying those words and make it even more
exciting.
Yeah.
Could you start thinking.
All right,
well the question now is how much is it
going to take to fucking break that?
One guy was saying that travolta was
opening his asshole massage here.
I guess.
I guess the guy wasn't taking the hint
to open his cheeks,
which has a phone.
My God,
he opened his cheeks as he asking the
guy who was he asking him to fuck them
or just wanting to say ms dot rub rub
here.
Like I guess he was just getting it.
If it's truly,
there's probably just getting sick and
tired of fucking not having his body
language read the way he wanted.
Cheese.
An animal animal.
He doesn't give a fuck.
You're just whipping out his dick.
Bill Clinton's.
I've pulled that move though.
So many.
I'm not as aggressive as him,
but he's trying to convert straight.
Guys get Travolta.
I guess when you,
again,
you're on that level,
just getting someone gay to blow you.
It means nothing and saying,
I want to get a guy with a wife and kids
to stick this in his mouth.
That would be like you only going after
lesbians,
like how rude.
You know,
you're getting all creepy with lesbians
and going after them only.
Why?
Why are you doing that?
Yeah,
it's just a power thing and you know,
they don't want it.
You don't.
They don't,
they're not interested in what you're
selling,
but what he wants is the.
But he again,
he wants somebody who will do it.
What I want is when I get a massage,
if somebody jerks me off,
I like it because they have to leave
with no complaints.
We're going to tell you,
just checked me off for money.
What are you gonna complain about it and
go like,
Hey Jim,
you weren't nice to me.
He didn't take me out to eat.
Like you really do.
You pay for the banality of the
relationship.
Like,
like this is our relationship right
here.
You can not ask me for anything more if
I want to give you more meaning
emotionally,
that's great and if you want to receive
it,
that's great,
but you can't ask for it and get mad
when it's not gathered.
Because the totality of our relationship
was I handed you money.
So really weird psychology.
Well it's sort of like when you go to
his trip club and all of a sudden the
girls are coming up to you and talking
to you and asking you if you'd like a
dance,
like giving you attention.
Like what is this weird world where all
of a sudden these beautiful girls come
towards you.
You know,
it's a complete reversal of the real
live scenario.
That's one of the reasons why it's so
intoxicating and crazy when it actually
happens.
It's like,
even though you know they're doing it
for money,
my,
my goal is to blow load my pants in the
Strip club.
I've done that twice.
I've blown two loads of my pants.
That was my goal or whatever I did.
They start lap dancing maybe once in
vegas and once in New Orleans I was able
to get with Louis,
ramy and Pete Corey Alley.
They were outside the fucking strip club
and I walked out and I had on sat and
boxers and I had a fucking load all over
him and I opened my things and I'm like,
look how great is this fucking when I.
When you showed everybody your load me
smell your load once at the.
The open.
Anthony did I really?
You have to load like packed into your
belly button.
No.
You gave it to Iraq and Iraq almost
threw up.
Do you want me to smile?
You want to smell like.
All right,
I'll take a shot.
How was it?
It wasn't good.
Oh thanks Joe.
It was rough,
but you guys can't do that kind of stuff
much anymore it seems like,
right?
Or Center you guys.
Not really.
Honestly No.
I mean we were careful about saying
things that will get us sued and certain
extreme language,
but that's a self censorship and
anything with like bodily fluids that
are crazy about because the different
with ems article and series of article
is we are on everywhere in the US and
Canada and we don't want to have to deal
with community standards issue because
we're in every fucking corner of the
country country,
so the Tampa laws could possibly without
a doubt to you and they haven't gotten
sued and I don't think they ever will,
but they,
they'll like,
you never know.
You never want to give them a reason by
doing something that's unnecessary.
So again,
I understand why they self protect
because it doesn't cost anything for the
city.
Of course,
none of them any money.
Now you're a fairly conservative guy
will come.
So I wouldn't say you were very similar
to me in a lot of ways that people would
think that you'd be liberal,
but you're more of a pragmatist,
you're more pragmatic in your approach,
but you,
you're on like red eye all the time on
Fox and it was all this.
What if a guy that gets into the White
House next,
if someone,
if it,
you know,
I don't know what Mitt Romney's ideas
are,
but if someone is like really right wing
and they get.
And what does it meant?
Romney's ideas about language.
What does his ideas about censorship?
It's more of a moderate.
I'd be to be honest,
because he was,
he was evil.
He was the governor of Massachusetts at
one point.
I don't think you can be that
conservative and run Massachusetts.
I think he's more moderate than say.
A lot of conservatives would be.
Well if we say if they got a Republican
candidate that was a more conservative,
more radical sort of a right wing top
type of dude.
We mean the.
We usually see some lockdowns on the
Internet easily could see at least some
attempts at censorship of online content
and censorship of satellite radio,
perhaps moving the FCC deciding that the
government needs to expand its,
you know,
maybe those make some sort of a
connection between certain events that
have happened and you know,
what maybe we need to tone down our
standards and make things a little bit
nicer and they might go.
I mean know that satellite radio is
able.
Any fucking person could just turn it on
and listen to it.
That's not outside the realm of
possibility that they would try to to
clamp down and sensor satellite radio.
It just like they have censored
broadcast TV.
Well they tried to get their hands on
it.
They tried already,
but because it's a subscription service,
they that because that opens a can of
worms where they would have to.
Hbo would then have to allow and then
they'd have to.
Because you don't have nothing on cable,
is regulated by the FCC.
They can't touch it because it's a
subscription service.
So I don't know if they'll ever be able
to get into that because that's too much
of a of a violation where the public
airways,
their argument is the argument.
But I don't think they have any shot at
getting.
Well,
I don't think.
I don't know.
I don't think they would either,
but I think they could.
I think it is possible if the right
person was an office,
you know,
so much of this country relies on
momentum and win with ideas.
Especially like,
you know,
people that decide what people
shouldn't,
shouldn't be able to say when you know,
when someone says you can't say faggot
or someone says you can't say retard or
someone says.
And we really go after people that do
that.
You start,
you get into a very tricky situation
where it's like,
who decides what can and can't be said
and that that's a weird thing when
everybody's pulling back,
when everybody's holding off and not
honestly expressing themselves.
Like you can't just completely eliminate
words and the vocabulary because you've
decided that they hurt feelings too
much.
Because what about all the fun times you
have called someone a fucking retard,
the.
There's some great moments in life where
you say,
Oh my God,
I'm a fucking retard and your friends
are how old and and laugh and you're
saying you shouldn't be able to do that
anymore.
It shouldn't be able to have a positive
thing.
It shouldn't be able to be a fun word
that you can express either on the radio
or through friends,
you know.
Really is it only negative and only
because of the fact that some people
negatively react to it.
Now it has to be eliminated really well.
Again,
once again,
once the naacp buried the word nigger,
they had that maybe that they had like a
symbolic funeral and I understood why
Michael Richards.
I think what he did was shitty because
he was yelling at an angle.
There's a huge difference between that
and saying something in the context of a
joke,
but once that happened,
once one word goes,
even though that's a reprehensible word
and it has a horrible history attached
to it,
that word has a history attached to it
that most words don't.
So dehumanizing word.
And it was.
Yeah,
and it was used a lot.
I mean,
and it was used in a direct,
uh,
oppression.
There's a lot of reasons why it's a
tremendously damaging word,
but the fact that it was quote unquote
removed.
Now everybody justifiably says,
look,
well,
if I get hurt,
be retard hurts me.
This hurts me.
And eventually it's going to go into
other words.
So you can't respect any of it.
I self-censor like you do because I make
decisions on what the reaction is going
to be.
Is it going to get me the reaction I
want?
But you can't fucking regulated.
You can't regulate lenny.
Bruce had it right in the fucking
fifties.
He's like,
if you just say it over and over again,
it won't mean anything.
And that weren't hurt.
Some little kid's feeling right.
You call him a nigger,
won't mean anything.
Yeah,
he was right.
But I mean they.
But they ruined them.
I mean,
he's so sad because you just wanted to
do is act for the court just for one of
them to see that it wasn't obscene and
like fucking,
you know,
it's really a sad fucking terrifying
store.
It is.
Heroin,
all of it together without the heroin
that still would want to know what I
mean.
Fucking ruined his life.
Of course.
I mean he was the,
the original groundbreaker,
but it's almost like you have to have a
guy who's just completely wild,
like lenny,
the Kinda guy that would get hooked on
heroin.
You'd almost have to have that guy.
It'd be the first guy to really step out
like that.
But I'm conservative about stuff like
that,
like about,
about terrorism.
I'm conservative about crime,
certain tax issues,
but I'm very liberal about things like
gay marriage,
like the liberals have really lost me on
language.
I began to hate liberals because the
language obsession,
but the conservatives with their whole
antigay stance,
I fucking hate them for like I hate.
Well,
the conservatives,
the problem on the conservative side too
is that during the Reagan
administration,
it got attached with fundamental
Christianity.
That's when,
that's when they really started to go
after that,
that vote,
because it's a strong there they,
they unite,
you know,
the churches are together and groups are
together and they,
you know,
they unite,
unite.
They'll rally and boycotts certainly
antichristian things,
you know,
especially if something is,
sacrilegious or whatever they would
think it would be.
That would be wrong.
So they rally and they make a lot of
fucking noise.
But to boycotts work though,
like Selma in the sixties.
But look what happened to Jack Halford.
He was on one of the new shows and he
said something about the,
uh,
the thugs,
he was talking about the Chinese
government and he said something kind of
a lot of flack on CNN.
And there was Chinese people with pro
agent protesting.
They were very upset.
She had ended in fucking budge.
Nothing happened.
How many of these things,
because there's always a bigger news
cycle right after it.
And again,
this is a,
I don't mean to take away from the
Virginia Tech massacre,
but a few weeks after,
I'm Mr.
two weeks after the Virginia Tech Mass,
a tech massacre happened.
It takes people's blind off that and
then nobody's focusing on it.
The news isn't covering it.
So the boycotts,
the boycotts are meaningless.
You just gotTa fucking plow through it
and ignore it or,
or take it on and pointed out for the
phony shit that it is.
And the boycott will probably not work.
That's what you have to do.
You have to put it out for the phone and
shit.
There it is.
You know,
it has to be just come on to stop when
the problem is when networks buckle and
know companies buckle and then they do
and they do sure there they're
terrified.
They only see the negative.
The island,
they only see the negative.
They only see.
They don't see any positive aspect in
standing your ground on a controversial
issue.
That's,
you know,
I,
because there's a bunch of fucking self
righteous douche bags out there that'll
get on twitter or get on facebook and
make these big long.
I supported your company and I was
always up until you this and just come
on,
stop.
Have you gained.
It seems like he's,
he stands behind most of the time.
I'm sure this things that bothered Dana,
but he seemed like he kind of stands
behind his guys if he,
what he feels is said is reasonable and
not like I kind of in the guys like
doing the trash,
talking to Dana White.
Like when things have popped up in the
publicly,
he seems like,
you know,
like,
like you had a thing and you fucking,
you know,
whatever it he didn't dump you,
which I was happy to see a couple of
other things he didn't dump guys for and
I kind of respected the way that company
handled things on a case by case basis
and didn't just overreact to every
complaint.
Yeah.
Well you know,
they're not dumb.
They didn't get to run the UFC by being
dumb or being people that conform to
other people's ideas.
I mean Dana and Lorenzo and frank,
they're just bad motherfuckers.
They,
they organized this whole thing.
The amount of work that guy does is
mindboggling staggering.
These constantly flying here and there
and,
and Lorenzo to their international
flights and constantly fucking working
on new deals and expanding the,
the,
uh,
the UFC all over the world.
And they now they got the ultimate
fighter in Brazil.
We just did one.
There was,
they sought 20 million people.
Saw it in Brazil.
$20 million people saw it in Brazil.
Wrap your head around that dude.
You never seen crowds like these
Brazilian crowds.
They go fucking crazy.
They go crazy before the fight even
started in between fights.
They were doing the wave and going nuts.
They fucking loved it.
So,
you know,
oh,
I saw all the Brazilian guys one on that
five minute.
Like who?
Who except for BC over doom and a rich
Franklin was thinking of.
Oh yeah,
a while ago where.
Oh,
you're taking about joe say Aldo and
Sharon does.
Yeah,
no,
this was this past weekend.
Yeah,
it was,
it was awesome.
It was fucking incredible,
incredible fights.
But what I was saying is like Dana is,
he's not a dumb guy,
you know,
he's,
he's way too smart to give into the
stupid shit that's involved in political
correctness.
He stands his ground and speaks his
opinion about everything.
And so what he wants from the guys in
the company is to just represent
yourself as professionally as possible
and you know,
and,
and try to try to try to promote
yourself and the guy like Chael Sonnen
knows how to do that.
You don't have to tell him how to do
that.
He figures out how to do it.
He knows how to write thing.
She says hilarious Shit,
stays in character and he backs it up
with the fact that it could fight his
fucking ass off.
Yeah,
he's a scary guy.
He's a nightmare.
And he's a smart dude,
man.
He's a very smart dude.
Smart Dude that can beat the fuck out of
you.
What do you think?
Do you,
were they scared to have him fight in?
Because I wondered like what he was when
I already filled in Brazil and it's
fucking scary.
I was scared because I was going to be
ringside.
It's like,
man,
if he wins this,
see this place could get nasty because
he said a lot of nasty shit about Brazil
countries and about Brazilians.
Brazilian people are extremely proud.
So it's an incredible place.
It's such a friendly culture.
I mean,
I know they have crime and they have
problems,
but it is like these martial arts
events,
the MMA events that we've had,
there are so fucking fun.
The crowds are so enthusiastic and no
Douche bags at all.
Everybody there for a party,
everybody there for a good time.
They really rude on those American or a
route on those Brazilian fighter show.
And when American guy wins,
they get fucking pissed man.
What do you think's going to happen?
I mean,
I know it's hard to make a prediction,
but I mean,
I,
I'm so fucking into.
I'm going into this fight with Bob Kelly
and we're doing this thing.
We're just talking to people and uh,
you know,
for,
for all and a,
and A.
I can't believe how fucking site Dan for
this fight.
I'm so sorry.
Why didn't move favorite,
by the way?
Do you know why?
Because Joe say Aldo injured his leg and
we supposed to defend his title in
Calgary Against Eric Koch.
But although had a leg injury,
so they decided to create a,
um,
interim title.
So a tenant versus Uriah Faber for the
interim title and they moved that.
Um,
and I think that's a fucking spectacular
fight,
man.
Hanan Barao was awesome,
I'm bummed out that we don't get to see
the Joseph Aldo fight,
but he's,
uh,
he'll be back,
but they weren't going to be fighting in
vegas anyway.
No,
that was,
um,
where was that one?
I'm going to be that Calgary.
Calgary.
Yeah.
That was Calgary.
It's hard to keep track of them all.
Sometimes down.
You're still lucky,
dude.
It's like you.
If you're one of the few guys who have
likened really love what you do too.
I don't like.
I
love Lou.
I think louise,
a genius.
I don't watch the show because I'm
afraid I'll be influenced by it.
I'm afraid like other comedians who I,
who I love,
I'll be influenced by like watching,
but you're doing something that when
you're doing the UFC,
I can't,
I don't,
I'm not gonna announce UFC so I can just
love what you're doing.
And I told you I think the best
announcement.
Sports.
Oh,
thank you.
Love.
I love watching those events and
listening to you do it and it's really
nice to enjoy a friend doing something
because I literally can't do that.
It's nice to enjoy.
I have friends that are musicians and I
really love watching musicians play
because I have no musical talent,
no connection to music.
So to me it's just,
I'm just watching someone play a fucking
guitar brilliantly.
I just get,
I get a jazz out,
you know,
it's,
it is a weird thing though that I know
his hands.
There's a.
and I don't.
By the way,
I don't mean that I don't enjoy your
comedically.
I know,
I know exactly what you're saying.
You,
I,
you know,
when we watch comedians,
sometimes I try to be a fan of comedy
because I really do love it.
So I do watch a lot of Comedians I've
watched guys I work with and I don't
worry about it influenced me too much.
I think I pretty much had my own idea of
what I do now,
but I know the feeling that,
I mean we've all been influenced by
other comedians and we've all caught
her.
So when I was young I caught myself
doing Richard Jenny wants on stage and I
really realized I was doing it,
you know,
it's like,
it sounded like,
um,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
it just sounded so disgusting,
you know?
So it's,
it's a sort of a natural thing sometimes
to be influenced by someone that you
admire or someone who does really well.
It's like catching yourself in the
mirror when you're walking to get the
comrade.
Just give a glance at yourself as you're
fucking looking down your leg and you're
like,
oh wow,
what happened to the load everywhere?
And you're like,
oh yeah,
you gotta fucking penguin walk.
You're like,
how did this fuck fuck is wrong with me?
I bet you that's what it's like.
If you're washing off a strap on the
catch yourself in the fucking bathroom
mirror.
Yeah,
and you're not doing a good job and you
have to go back and clean it more.
Yeah.
You just keep smelling it when you
finish everything to alk to throw it
back.
Whoa.
Jesus.
Yeah.
You can't reuse a strap on it.
I mean,
it should be something that it's,
it's,
you know,
it's so rare that you can spend 30 bucks
and throw in the trash and throw it out
real bad.
You know?
It shouldn't be happening so often that
you're like,
well,
I've got to keep a fucking good box of
clean ones nearby.
You never want to wear one out.
Like you never want to go like,
wow,
this is only.
This has seen better days would I wonder
what the world record is for straight
guys that have taken it up the ass with
a strap on.
I wonder if there's.
Who cares about.
No,
I'd love to know that.
I'll never break it,
but I'll admire whoever.
Got It.
Yeah.
There's certain things in the world
record where you're like,
Gee,
I mean,
how badly do you want to be recognized?
You creep.
Yeah.
Grand.
Grow your fingernails 15 feet long and
kill the nerves in your arm.
You know,
they,
those guys grow their fingers.
They have,
they suffer permanent nerve damage.
They just look like they're hand smell.
Oh yeah,
like they don't.
You ever smelled like under a nail.
It's not good.
Well,
those nails are insane.
Like you're not some kind of crazy
obsession who's you've ever seen those?
It's really nutty.
Pull up a picture of the guy who won the
world's record for the longest nails
because this guy like literally his arm
became useless.
Is He Indian?
Yes.
I think I've seen him and he just wanted
to get in that Guinness Book,
man.
To him,
it was so important that he gave up the
use of one of his arms just so he could
grow the longest nails and they look
like a tree.
He looks like he looks at me and
asshole.
Oh my God,
look,
look how nutty that is.
But he just looks like an Asshole,
but bottled people tell him like,
you look stupid.
Oh my God.
Is that her nails?
That's like jazz hands.
They can't be real.
They're real.
Yeah.
That's Jasean Wolverine.
Come on man.
As they say,
they're real,
of course is.
Why would a woman,
what does it say?
World's longest number home.
She's a giant head to her.
Head off a god that is instills nails
are insane.
SRN myfreecams.
Oh my God.
How does she even wipe her pussy?
Yeah,
right.
Exactly.
To backup.
Check that shit out.
And look at video.
EPA tests on her.
They're all short right there.
That's why they are so short.
They're,
oh my God,
these are wolf clause.
This is so strange.
Um,
I just kind of a challenge to myself to
see how far they would go before they
started twisting out of shape and I
couldn't cut on.
So they just kept growing and growing
and I kept setting dates and dates that
I was gonna do it.
And then I started getting all of this
out worldwide notoriety.
And,
and then it's strange how they be come
part of you.
Exactly what her house looked like,
a writer,
a in the Midwest,
although her nails go under her forearm
while she was writing,
the door was open and I looked out and I
could see the road going and um,
I just felt kind of like a section and I
remember nothing after the feeling of
being sucked out of the vehicle,
the first thing I spotted was a
fingernail and I did.
Oh,
I kind of started to cry.
There's one of my fingernails.
Oh,
that's great.
I couldn't,
I couldn't have had a better ending as
far as I'm concerned.
Fucking brokered dumb nails.
Good ahead.
That is crazy.
I wonder if her nails were the fault of
the accident,
right?
She probably couldn't steer properly.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
I probably couldn't grip the fucking
thing.
Look at this guy here.
Oh my God.
That's the Indian guy.
Oh,
look at those things.
There's.
Oh,
that's so much.
A woman's Pussy CEO.
She had the woman's longest nails,
but this motherfucker's got the longest
nails in them.
Shits are ridiculous.
That's,
that's a totally different animal.
I think that's more needier.
How much did you love to fucking just
acts those?
Oh
No.
Changed and I became so that pushed me
to keep my conviction,
snails,
alien,
nails.
She went what they taste like.
Oh my God,
look,
he's got taped together.
A tape has gotten yellow.
Look how gross that is taped up and
it's.
It swings around in a big circle around
his thumb.
I would not want to eat at this
restaurant now.
Hey Kevin,
the guy quit.
Fucking arm is worthless.
Useless.
He gave up use of his left arm just to
be a cool guy with the longest nails,
but who I.
This is white.
That tell them that there's look
terrible.
I don't know man.
In India people are different in
different parts of the world would have
been India.
That's the shit.
It's probably like a hoarder.
It's probably like a disease and mental
disease probably,
right?
You can have like a sense of
accomplishment.
So there's one thing in your life that
you know is normal or awesome or
something thing.
You're good at cutting your nails.
What a shitty thing.
It'd be so crazy.
The idea that somehow or another there's
value,
but it is because people are paying
attention to them.
Yeah,
but not good attention.
People pay attention to Sandusky too,
but nothing like,
you know what I mean?
Is it's bad reasons.
Yeah.
But they're not angry at him.
They're like,
well,
they want to look at it.
Maybe that's all he needs.
You know?
He just needs someone to want to stare
at them.
And just a reaction.
I mean,
is it even positive?
It's like woo.
Like people look at it,
they look at it and it's not,
it's,
it's horrific for sure.
It's disgusting.
But it's also energetic.
You're like,
oh whoa.
To him it might be just that.
Just the fact that everywhere he goes,
there's no denying that he gets a
significant reaction,
you know?
So that's enough.
So it gives him like important.
So it gives them something.
You think he's a very uninteresting guy
and that's the one time people show
interest.
Like every story he Kelsey,
but probably zone out.
He probably sees their eyes going up in
the air.
He's probably a terrible bore it all he
talks about is fucking stupid nails all
day.
Do you think he segues every
conversation,
tries to steer it back to his fucking
stupid left.
His wife wants to talk about the news.
That is a guy in Pakistan who thinks he
can grow longer.
Nails done me.
Fuck you.
I say to him,
fuck you.
I will never quit.
He thinks I would have quit and he just
gets mad when he hears about dudes,
try and take his crown one if there's
like a,
an online giant nail community where
they can like check does.
There's like fat websites were dudes
would try to gain weight a purpose and
like taught like it was like sort of a
bear thing and talk about a hot.
Their guts looked to end a relationship
that's A.
Brian hates himself and do a fucking
sponge shape.
Like so disgusted with me.
They break up with me.
I got a lot of weight to lose now guys.
So that's a hilarious joke and should
talk about that on stage because it's so
funny.
And in his truck accident have you
should do it more often.
It's really hard to get like a fucking
pig man.
Dude.
I hit my body.
It's just where the speed alone.
I just forget
to eat and I'm like,
Oh shit,
I really need to eat because I'm not
gonna be able to eat for like five
hours.
What do I have jack in the box.
All right.
You know?
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons I like being
home so much.
One of the favorite things is because I
can actually eat real food and control
what I eat and actually go to the
supermarket and having to eat at
restaurants all the time.
And plus the temptation.
Like if you're hungry and you're out in
the road and you see a Wendy's double
cheeseburger pretty fucking good right
now,
but you work out so much.
I went out with you wanting to Austin
and we a fucking pancakes,
like you had a man's meal.
I'm trying to nibble on salmon,
like a fucking fruit.
And I'm like,
you know what?
Because you do.
How many of you work out for so long?
You can.
You can get away with that,
you can't let it,
let it get out of hand.
You know,
you can only keep eating pancakes and
shit as long as you're actually eating
regular food on the most for the most
part,
like healthy food for the most part.
And then when that pancake comes up you
deserved that bitch go crazy.
How often do you give yourself that
cheat?
Like that?
Every couple of days.
Every three or four days.
I try to do it every day,
but I don't restrict myself.
Like if one day I'm like at the coffee
shop and a coconut macaroon looks extra
delicious.
Coconut macaroon.
How often you work out?
Almost every day.
Just the.
The key is to just keep.
I take at least one or two days off a
week depending on the week,
but the key is to keep it mostly
positive,
mostly healthy and you know,
90 percent really good food.
Ninety percent solids on it.
But if you ever want to get some
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
come on man.
I just have some chicken.
I would love to actually still really
haven't had KFC in years.
You know what,
I like it.
I like KFC cold with hot sauce.
I take that Liu Kotecha Habanero sauce.
That's the shit.
You can only get it.
Mexican supermarkets.
I order it online on Amazon.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Oh Dude.
And you pour some of that hot sauce and
then dip the chicken in there until your
fucking mouth wants to it.
Like that.
I have to pee.
I have to piss desperately covered in
Piss.
Fuck.
Yeah.
But I don't,
I try not to,
um,
to eat too much of that shit.
But when I want to eat something that's
Shitty,
I fucking eat it.
Yeah.
It's fun actually eat with you because
we order so much and it's kind of
getting.
It's kind of like,
hey,
let's get to see that half the menu all
at once.
Kind of like a,
you're an employee and it's your first
day of training and they usually cook
one of everything.
You kind of do that in some ways and
you'll,
you'll have like,
oh,
I have just a little piece of this
that's only after like to show
if we do like to show somewhere and then
become a glutton.
I've never seen anyone though my whole
life eat like you till I met you.
Like I've never heard of ordering more
than one appetizer that was new to me.
There was also,
there are so many things that when I
first got to meet you that,
that was so shocking to me.
Now I find myself doing them all the
time,
like talking about masturbating.
I never would talk about my masturbation
out the public to anybody,
you know.
And now I talk about all the time.
You're like,
broke that wall or whatever.
What was down before.
You've done a lot to me and I think
you're very influential with a lot of
people that listen to this podcast and
friends and masturbating and talk to you
about it.
They're all debating talking about it.
And
well,
you know,
I think we all influenced each other.
You know,
I think,
uh,
there's a positive things that we can
learn from all that from everybody,
but uh,
you know,
shouldn't be worried about talking about
masturbating.
Yeah,
that was weird.
It's all weird.
This one of the things I love about
Norton,
he doesn't give a fuck.
I'll talk about anything.
He's just so crazy.
Sometimes shocks me,
you know,
I hear him talk about things like his
girlfriend [inaudible] and with a strap.
Ah,
I want to protect them.
Like don't say it anymore.
Stop.
Now this is too crazy.
The urine step.
He's awesome.
You know,
this,
uh,
when you know,
the other thing that happened to you as
you got into the world of the standup
comedian,
you went from the world of the computer
salesman or a regular person to the
world of the standup comedian,
which is in the world,
I think becoming a stripper in the world
of becoming a part of a weird community
of,
uh,
of miscreants,
you know,
and have a of artistic types and you
know,
and,
and creative types.
And then a lot of fucking weird people.
Man.
You know,
so it's like your whole reality changes,
so that's why like the other day when
you were in that club and uh,
jokes and people in the audience were
like freaking out and pat in their head
with Napkins,
you got to realize they're not.
If they're not around fun people,
right.
They're not,
they don't get that opportunity.
I mean,
one of the,
I think Jimmy,
I bet you agree that one of the best
things about being a comic is that
you're friends with comics get to hang
out with comics.
Like,
like a guy like Colin or like,
like,
you know,
jody is like,
you get to hang out with Brian Kaplan,
you know,
you get to hang out with people who were
fucking really entertaining and fun to
be around all the time.
You know,
it's,
it's a really weird thing with comics.
Like I,
I do think my friends,
I'm friends with the funniest people in
the country and I was on a plane going
back to New York and Seth Meyer was on
the plane and I didn't know.
I didn't know if it 100 percent him.
I've never met him,
but I knew it was really weird cool
feeling to know that at the end of the
flight to I think he's great and I
wanted to tell them that and I knew that
I could as a comic and I knew that he,
he might not know a lot of what I've
done,
but I knew he would recognize my face
and I would be able to talk to them.
For them it was really weird,
like that's what it feels like to be an
accurate and see another actor.
Like I'm psyched whenever I fucking see
a comic I like and I know I can just go
up and say hello to them and even if
they don't know who I am,
if I say I'm a comic,
like Joan rivers when I met,
didn't know who I was,
but when she found out I was a comic,
she had her road manager fucking passed
me a newspaper.
She like,
yeah.
She said,
you look like you need something to
read.
I was on the plate and doing nothing.
So I was like,
it was just a nice bond to have.
Yeah.
And I love,
love being in front of the comedian.
Yeah,
it's a.
especially because I think both you and
I,
you know,
when we started out,
we would look at professional comedians
with such all in reverence,
you know,
the idea that one day you were going to
actually be a professional,
you know,
you,
you're a real comic and then now you get
to hang out with real comics and you're
actually like working with these people
and you know,
and they're like the people that you
admire when you were at or the idea of
the people that you admired when you
were a kid,
you know,
and to know that they respect you and
that you're,
that you're welcome in the group.
It sounds
like as we always want to be accepted
and to know that you're not an outcast
comic,
but his comments that some guys look at
it and you never want to be that guy
because that's got to be awful.
But to know that other comics like me,
you know,
either they don't enjoy my act,
they liked me personally.
It's fun.
It's a nice feeling and it's a feeling
of belonging,
which is very important.
Absolutely.
Humans like to be accepted when every
human wants to be accepted,
and the crazy thing about comedy is you
asking for acceptance for you going out
on crazy limbs.
I mean you're going out on a limb where
you're standing on stage demanding
people's attention and trying to make
them react a certain way and laugh,
which is incredibly difficult.
You could never get a computer to figure
out how to do it.
There's,
there's A.
There's nuances and subtleties to it
that really only exists organically.
I don't know.
I think they will.
They they with chess,
it was the same thing.
They got Kasparov and those are moves,
those moves,
those are numbers.
So that's a little to the left,
one of the right.
You know,
it's,
it's a big difference between that and
the idea of humor.
You might be able to get some humor.
You're never going to figure out Joey
Diaz on a computer.
What's funny is that he's really Joey
Diaz,
right?
You know what's funny is that's the real
dude.
He really doesn't give a fuck.
You can suck his dick.
He gets up at eight in the morning and
goes right to the puck and pot
dispensary.
Like a doctor.
Like that's.
Yeah,
that's.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like he's a,
he's a real human,
you know,
like you can't event,
uh,
Patrice on a computer.
You're not going to do it.
You're not going to figure it out.
Yeah.
It was a,
I don't know.
Have you tried alienware tried to
portray is funny.
Fuck man.
Oh,
he was awesome man at any guys.
I don't give a fuck guys.
He and,
and he really again,
another guy who just didn't.
I think at times he,
he probably should have like when you
look back over history,
like yeah,
he probably would've been farther along
if he had cared earlier on,
but the business finally couldn't ignore
them at the end.
Like after the shooting Roche,
like Oh,
that's what this guy does and they
couldn't ignore it anymore.
And of course that's going to die.
Well,
you know what I mean?
He's real hard for a lot of great comics
to figure out how to market themselves,
you know,
we all know guys like Nick Depaulo,
who's one of the fucking funniest guys
ever.
Unbelievable.
Depaul's a great standup comedian.
I saw him again the last time I was in
New York.
I went by Caroline's just on a like a
random night and for whatever reason it
wasn't working.
Oh,
it was the night before I was supposed
to work.
That's what it was and I didn't know
that depaul was going to be there and
right before he got on stage I arrived.
So I sat in the audience like,
like an like an audience member.
I just sat and watched the entire set
and I was fucking crying,
crying.
That dude is funny.
He's fucking brilliant.
He's so.
And he's always writing,
doing something about the Katrina
victims not getting rescued because they
couldn't spell help.
Said Hep,
you want to have your fucking fingers in
that water.
You want some happy.
Dip your fingers in the water and it's
not just a personalized.
The tagline is fucking is equally
brilliant and punchline.
It was just so mean and so,
so like fucking Boston,
you know,
there's that certain style of comedy
that again,
people would protest for sure.
There's a lot of shit that depaulo would
say that people would get mad at it,
but it's funny to watch the funny.
It's funny to watch him at the cellar
when they get upset because he,
nick has no fucking fuse.
He immediately gets annoyed at them when
they grown you.
This is the seller,
like more sensitive.
Oh,
well,
you know,
they don't know who they're walking in
to see.
A lot of them are tourists and then
Nicole go on and sometimes she'll say to
them as genuinely harsh like that.
I'm in the back on the UHF and like one
girl in the frog.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Fucking Nyu constantly just blast the
entire room.
I just love the fact that he has no
patience for the objection.
I've seen Nick Depaulo get mad at people
from crossing their arms.
Let's fucking guy crossing his arms
looking at me here.
Yeah.
What are your board?
You don't even fuck.
You don't think that's funny piece of
shit.
But a guy like that,
I don't even like to watch because he's
such a good comic and he's so funny and
it's going to be as good as that guy.
All I do is measure myself.
I tell I'm on the road with,
I'm doing gigs with rd and nick and tell
we're doing these gigs together,
the four of us.
And it's like,
it's uncomfortable to watch a towel.
It's like he's so brilliant.
And I'm like,
why don't you just enjoy it?
Can you just enjoy it?
I probably should.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
You can do it.
You know what,
man,
I,
I used to think the same way.
I used to think like,
wow,
I don't want to.
I used to not want to watch somebody
because then I would bomb if I went on
after them because I'd be thinking about
their assets and judging my own act and
saying fuck,
I'm going to say I suck at this guy.
But then somewhere along the line I
learned how to just laugh.
I learned how to just watch comedy and
just enjoy it and not worry about like
my own shit.
And just like,
I have no it work before,
don't,
you know,
don't be so attached to it,
but don't,
don't worry about it.
Just just do the work,
do the work that it takes to create an
act that's good enough so you don't have
to worry about it and then enjoy it.
So like when I go on the road and I take
it with me or Duncan or Joey Diaz,
I like watching.
I like standing on the sidelines and
watching Joey Diaz.
I like howling with laughter.
It's fun.
I don't think holy shit,
he's killing.
I go on right next.
I never think that.
I think this is awesome.
This is fun.
Like I want to watch a guy who's
hilarious is making me laugh,
you know?
I think that was just a shift in my
consciousness.
I just had to kind of understand things
better.
I didn't get get older,
you know?
And once I figured that out it changed
the way I looked at comedy.
It's funny man,
it's so hard to do that.
I,
you know,
you get so quick like I used to,
it used to be I had to feel negative
before I went on and I had to feel like
I suck and I'm not going to do.
I was almost lowering all expectations.
So if I bomb,
I kind of knew.
Now I don't do that and I kind of assume
a guy will be good.
You know,
you've been around long enough.
How bad does it feel when you go
onstage?
Cocky,
and I've done this before and I've seen
people do it before and you eat it,
you go onstage,
cocky,
you don't ingratiate yourself somehow or
another,
you miss the connection initially with
the audience and then you're,
you're already running on borrowed time.
You know what I mean?
Then you fucking feel like you can't get
any traction and then you're forcing
bits and like we were
talking about earlier,
like over a motion and so gross that
when you just,
you didn't approach the,
the,
the thing with enough fear.
You didn't approach it with enough
reverence.
You know,
you've got cocky,
you thought you're just going to be able
to.
I've seen Joey Diaz do that.
I've seen him have bad sets because of
that.
It's just,
it's one of those things,
you know,
I think we all do.
I mean I think we all go through when
you go up and you just like,
I'm in a fucking hammer,
these people and then you go up and then
once you miss the connection it's
usually you can salvage something.
Like I was worried tonight when I went
out and I sat on panel because the first
couple of jokes were like,
Eh,
well you had 14 year old girls in the
audience though.
That scared me because I'm like,
this is a fucking pig show.
You fuck it.
And then you start all those years of
doing gigs.
You start reaching for like,
you know,
how to manipulate your act and your set
and what are you doing to kind of make
it work?
And I knew where to go where I could get
a laugh and it was like I did that
totally playing to these people in this
audience and not to the millions of
people around the world that we're
listening to you.
While I was doing stuff that I wanted to
do anyway,
but I cut certain things and winter in a
different order because even though I'm
talking to the people at home,
you want the people at home to see you
doing well because even though they're
going to laugh with her and laugh at it,
if they see you,
you don't want to bomb on a shelf.
That'd be hard,
stank.
Even if the jokes were good,
the evidence proves that they weren't
good right here.
I laughed at home.
Fuck you.
These people in the audience didn't
laugh at all.
Yeah.
It was uncomfortable.
Like they just going to be uncomfortable
for you.
It doesn't mean no.
This is a big shot.
Especially since you have this history
of talking about all of your perversions
and then here you are in front of 14
year old girls.
Just about anything that's on your mind.
Whatever bit you were about to do.
I how many you would never have expected
that would have been your crowd before
you got there,
right?
Well,
I knew it because they told me that I
was posted to this Friday with a WHO's
there,
Andrew Garfield is playing spiderman.
I was going to be on the couch with him,
which would have been perfectly similar,
uh,
audience,
I'm sure that demo and what I'm looking
for.
But then they said,
look,
because of the finals,
everything's good.
We want to put you on Wednesday,
which is a much bigger shell because
it's the middle of the week and you
know,
Justin Bieber's on it.
And I'm like,
ugh.
I'm like,
I don't know if I,
I almost didn't want to do it because I
realized the size of the show is
different,
but I'm like,
I don't want to eat my fucking balls and
you'll be fine and faith in you.
And,
and,
and again,
I pulled it out.
But um,
it could've been a disaster.
It was a disaster waiting to happen.
That was such a shit audience for your
sense of humor.
You have a perverted sense of humor and
it's all.
A lot of it is,
you know,
even the clean stuff is like,
people know,
like there's always this wink,
wink,
hint,
hint that you're a perv now under the
surface of it all,
they didn't know what the happy ending
was.
Like I said,
it was a happy ending.
The jokes,
the,
it was a happy ending in the end that I
did it and you let destroys in clubs,
but they were all like,
Huh,
why would he do what happened?
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
I almost started tugging my tie.
No respect.
Oh,
it was fucking panicking man.
And my heart to think about like playing
to the people at home that must've been
able to realize that you were in front
of some 14 year old girls,
like especially your fans.
I did,
but I,
I again,
I wanted to do decent because again,
Mila Kunis is on the couch next to me.
It's like I don't want to bomb in front
of this fucking left.
She was great by the way.
He was really fucking cool.
Yeah,
she was very nice.
And uh,
it helps when somebody on the couch kind
of with you laugh a little in the
background.
I did panel on time with Bill Maher and
I was not supposed to do with another
comedian,
but the lead guest canceled so they just
got more last minute that they never put
to stand up on a panel and they told me,
look,
certain things you are going to talk
about,
this is like Darren Mccain,
Obama running bill's going to talk about
it.
So I had to switch my set and a.
But bill was surprisingly supportive on
panel,
which really fucking helped a lot
because that could have been a
disastrous situation.
I found out when I was in the store
trying to buy a t shirt an hour before I
had to go over to NBC.
Like,
look,
we've got some new bill Maher is going
to be and how you're going to have to
change what you.
So wow.
So you were on your way over there and
what bits did you have to do that?
We're with it.
I forget what I was talking about,
but it was something about Obama and
Mccain who was in like October or
whatever of Oh eight,
which is the last time I've done panels
because after that it was the Jay Leno
show and then all these bits I was
doing.
So it will be kind of interesting to see
your take after his take,
you know.
I mean as long as you're not doing the
same jokes,
what do you.
Why?
Why,
why aren't you allowed to.
I mean,
I probably could have,
I don't remember what their,
I don't think they said Donald,
but they might've said you might want to
rethink it.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
again to them to what is it at the,
uh,
that expect to comics to go up and both
of them.
Do you know McCain Obama jokes?
Yeah.
Know they probably wanted to switch and
just in tempo or tone,
two guys up there talking about the
exact same thing they might've felt it
would have been bad for me.
So what did you switch to this?
I don't remember.
I never watched a set when I'm feeling
like I won't watch tonight.
I mean I'll check it on twitter.
Let's hope it's a fucking good one
because I'll never say it.
Just make sure I do that after fights.
Sometimes I check to see if anybody says
I suck cocker.
Who would say that?
Honestly,
do a bunch of dudes that are haters make
a mistake or miss something in a replay
or something like that.
You know?
You never know.
People find something to be upset about
it.
I'm always amazed when you see because I
watched the UFC the way,
like I love it so much,
but I'm not.
I can't just.
I can't see what they're doing,
but when you go into like you better
watch that right hand.
I think it was Henderson.
Bisping was the best example that I ever
saw a when I at my advisor damage to
knock it out basically.
I think you were saying he's going to
walk right into his right.
Well it was really a classic mistake
that you do with a big puncher.
You move towards his power punch should
never do that because you kind of
accentuate the punch if you're running
away,
like especially if you kind of running
circular most of the time when you're
running away,
you're not really running straight back.
You're running side to side and this
bank continued to run towards Dan
Henderson's right side.
He was running towards his left,
so in fact he's actually accentuating
the punch is running into the power of
it,
so all Henderson has to do his time,
his move,
because it keeps going that way.
It's like he keeps giving it up.
He's not.
Frankie Edgar will go left and then
he'll go right now go left like Clay
Guido,
just fog gray maynard.
A lot of people thought that it was a
boring fight because you.
It went five rounds and quita had a hard
time engaging them,
but the bottom line is his movement is
what allowed him to stay safe because
that gray maynard is a fucking murderous
puncher that punches really hard.
So it he.
He played a smart footwork strategy.
Whether or not you liked the fight or
not,
for his safety,
his movement was excellent,
but bisping wasn't doing that.
This bank had made an error and kept
moving in the same direction.
And Dan Henderson,
I knew it was going to time that and
when it did,
it was like one of the greatest chaos in
like the history of the sport.
And that was one of the best one punch
knockout ever.
And the followup followup was ruthless.
What do you,
uh,
what he's going to fight Jon Jones
September for Henderson is.
Oh yes.
Oh yeah,
yes.
There Jones about that.
We'll interview them and you seem kind
of a.
he's like,
look,
if I can't be the guy in his forties and
a contact sport.
And that was his take on that.
What he really said.
Yeah.
He said something about that.
He said,
come on man.
He's like,
well,
he's so confident.
I mean,
you think about what the guy's done.
Go through Shogun.
Go.
Let me go through Machida.
Choke them unconscious and drop it in
the way he,
you know,
you beat rampage.
Went to rampage.
Choked rampage mean that's the rampage
is a tough motherfucker,
man.
John Jones is putting away some tough
guys.
Rashad Evans is a bad motherfucker.
Big decisions.
Rashad,
you know Rashad got a tough game.
I think a bit of a tougher time though.
I mean they went to or five rounds and
he couldn't.
He couldn't knock him out.
I need A.
I think he,
I think John's won all five rounds.
Well you know what,
Jones is bigger guy and Jones definitely
landed more shots and definitely forced
his game on Rashad,
you know,
were shot.
I think at one point in time when they
were training together was probably
better than Jon Jones.
But when a guy like Jon Jones comes
along,
it's like you,
you miss him for a month and then you
come back and you see them a month later
and you won't look.
I'm at the gym.
You look at him at the gym and he's like
15 percent pet.
Like this guy got 15 percent better in a
month and I'm not exaggerating.
There's certain dudes that just have
like an unbelievable ability to absorb
moves and then recreate them in,
in real time situations.
Like you could teach certain guys
Jujitsu techniques and then they could
just go out and do them and then you can
teach another guy.
You can teach them the same shit for 100
years,
will never fucking figure out how to
pull it off on a live person.
Do you think that,
uh,
with,
with Sunnen and Silva it,
do you think there's a lot of pr?
I mean there's a lot of pressure on
syllabus.
Do you think he has an undue amount of
pressure on them?
Well,
like John Jones Silva is a incredible
special athlete.
You know,
the,
what makes John Jones so amazing is that
you look at his,
his who's who of opponents since he
started the UFC,
and then you look back and see the guy's
only been around for four years in mma.
I mean,
it's really incredible what he's
accomplished.
You know,
Jon Jones is truly the newest next level
of athlete.
Anderson Silva is a totally different
story.
Anderson Silva is a real veteran.
He's a guy who at one point in time
didn't have a ground game and he has
some losses in the past and he's
vulnerability.
He's lost at the highlight on some
highlight,
real loose losses like Takahashi mounted
triangle or run Rio tone and hit him
with a flying wheel.
Hook,
eats,
flying,
scissors,
a sweep them like a fucking movie.
I mean he dove on his legs like pro
wrestling was crazy and then caught them
in a heel hook,
made him tap.
The whole thing.
Took like three seconds.
It was incredible.
You know,
so Anderson has tasted both victory and
defeat.
John Jones is a completely different
thing.
Jon Jones is a this new level,
this next level shit where he comes up
and you take all these veterans of the
game and he rag dolls,
ragdoll shogun.
I mean he ragdolled Shogun.
He jumping fucking kneed him in the
face.
The very first technique he throws and
he connects and then he just beat him
from pillar to post.
I mean it was never in trouble,
didn't see like Mochida hit them really
hard while like machita a really comes
from shots and he was fine.
Yeah,
I mean Machida is,
had the best result that anybody's had
against John in the first round.
It was probably one of the first rounds
that John's last in the UFC,
you know,
machita one,
that striking exchange.
So then John takes him to the ground and
smashes them and choke them unconscious.
I mean what he can do to guys when he
manhandled stewards is very unusual.
Anderson is a different dude.
Anderson is not unbelievably physically
strong with Anderson is like a super
technician who's really dedicated to the
game and has developed his game in front
of our eyes were at one point in time he
didn't have the ground game.
He was just mostly like a really bad ass
kickboxer that would try to take guys
heads down.
But then like a guy like Carlos Newton
got them down and mounted them and
really controlled.
I'm pretty easy on the ground.
Takahashi did the same thing in the
minute and fight.
I don't remember what they gave him a
red flag or a yellow yellow card rather,
or I think they took some money off of
Newton because they said he was
stalling,
so they stood them back up.
I think that's what happened,
but anyway,
the results over,
for whatever reason,
they stood back up.
Anderson Silva flying kneed him in the
face and stopped him,
but when he would get stuck on the
ground,
sometimes he would get tapped,
but he changed.
He changed and evolved and became a guy
with a full game and then in the jail,
son and fight.
That was real.
I mean,
he had already gotten Dan Henderson by
submission,
you know,
where he got Dan's back and then choked
him out.
I'm a trap tap Travis Luder with a
triangle tube,
but it was because he had travis luder
stuck in between his legs and he was
smashing it with elbows,
ruthless,
ruthless elbows,
but he developed a real ground game,
like a real Brazilian Jujitsu.
Black belt level ground is a black belt.
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
He's a real.
I mean,
not,
not just a black belt like he's.
He's very high level,
he's a really good.
When he caught Chael Sonnen with a
triangle that was some smooth technique
and it was the fifth round of a fight
where he was getting.
But he had lost every round I think did.
He did.
There's no question about it.
It would be a crime to state that he
didn't lose those rounds.
If anybody gave those rounds to Anderson
there should be arrested.
And do you think that jail,
I mean it shows you something.
It's obviously a heartbreaking loss,
but the fact that he kept going after
them instead of just dancing and staying
away for last couple of minutes,
which he could have done in easily won
the fight,
but channels an animal.
Well,
it's also there.
He was exhausted.
I mean you've got to realize he's fought
for and a half rounds going 150 miles an
hour taking the guy down,
lifting up,
near slamming them down,
you know,
in chill was on the podcast and he was
talking about how tiring it is and he
was,
he's really honest about shit like this.
One of the things I love about that guy,
he said that just you're not supposed
to,
a human body is not supposed to fight
five,
five minute rounds going full clip.
You just simply can't do it,
so you have to figure out how much
energy you're going to exert,
how you know you're going to try to pace
yourself.
You're going to try to slowly dragged
this fight out,
but you know if you completely go for
it,
like in the vandelay rich Franklin fight
that you see that design was great
fight.
Vandelay caught rich Franklin the second
round and almost put them away.
Had them really hurt,
jumped all over him,
swarmed on him,
but burned himself out because Franklin
survived and then in the third round
vandelay was done.
He was just exhausted and then Franklin
took them down,
beat him up,
and then the enemy,
it probably cost vandelay the fight
because he went for the knockout.
It's like a perfect example.
It's like you really can't go full clip
for five rounds.
Their body just doesn't work that way.
So you think like a sprint.
You can't sprint for 25 minutes,
you know what I mean?
There's one guy I'm dying to get on Opie
and Anthony,
like I've met him.
I've spoken to him briefly.
He said he would do it.
He wouldn't.
He's never in New York.
Oh,
well,
you know what man?
You talked to Dana White.
Especially if he wins,
you know,
I'm sure they're going to want to put
him on some crazy tort and even if he
loses,
he'll do a tour.
I hope so.
Yeah.
He'll do a tour.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's,
he's and he's a publicity machine.
That guy does everything.
It was funny.
I saw an interview you did with him
where he goes,
I'm not that fight promotion.
And you're like,
well actually what are you doing?
Think my balls for calling him out on it
because very funny.
Well,
it's fun to hear him defend himself too,
because he has the best definitions of
things where you just.
What he was talking about the fight,
like losing the fight.
He goes,
I did not lose to Anderson Silva.
I don't know where you come from,
but where I come from,
if you hold a man down and beat the shit
out of him for five rounds,
then he wraps his legs around your head
for eight seconds and he wins.
Yeah.
He does have a great way of like,
how many fighters would take that
approach?
I mean,
everybody else would take this approach
of,
you know,
try to be humble or try to say,
well,
you know,
God puts a mysterious plans in front of
me and I'm going to go back to the
drawing board and see what I can do.
And instead he pretends that he's
undefeated,
undisputed.
He brings a fake belt to the press
conferences.
I mean,
he just takes things to a completely
ridiculous and new and original level.
His level is very different.
Like his top trash talking,
in my opinion,
is so much more interesting than a guy
like Muhammad Ali because Muhammad Ali's
trash-talking was at least he was being
honest about his skills and he was being
honest about his past.
Like he's denying entire chapters is,
you know,
of his print,
his record undefeated.
Undisputed he says he's the champion.
It's funny,
just something really entertaining about
it,
but does that get distracting as a
fighter?
Like when you're fighting,
do you get distracted or caught up in
that out in the training camp,
but I wonder if that becomes a
distraction at all because you know,
you're so busy building this kind of
machine around you.
There's PR machine.
It's,
you know,
I mean I don't want to raise rocky three
is an example,
but I mean even though,
because he's on the losing end of it,
but it,
does that get distracting for a fighter?
It can.
It depends on the guy.
You know,
I,
I don't know how jail handles it,
you know,
but you think about how much trash you
talked before the first Anderson Silva
fight and he fought pretty fucking good.
But then again there's the talk that
Anderson was injured,
her fight that he had an issue,
you know,
I don't know how much of it played a
factor.
Anderson in the past has had issues with
some guys that were wrestlers like
Travis Luder,
but that was another fight that he took
injured.
I know for sure he was injured because
his manager told me after that fight
that Anderson had had meniscus surgery
on both knees just five weeks before
that fight.
It's incredible.
I mean,
the fact that he was able to have a cage
fight and defend the world title against
a tough guy like Travis Luder,
five weeks after meniscus surgery.
Cut your knee open man.
And they,
they trim out the,
a padded area.
Some of the padded area in between your
knee gets broken up and torn,
especially doing Jujitsu and wrestling.
A lot of guys tear,
tear their,
uh,
their tissue inside their knee and they
go in,
they scope it and they cleaned it up and
smooth it out.
And he kind of,
he fought five weeks later.
Have you had surgeries?
I've had that.
Yeah.
Five weeks later is incredible.
It's a fucking man.
Surgery.
Yeah.
Five weeks later it still hurts.
You know,
it's still sore when you get on your
knees,
you know.
And this guy is fighting.
I had my turbinates shrunk recently and
I felt like a warrior,
but they put the fucking needle in my
nose.
So I can read a little bit better.
I felt good about that.
But you get the fuck out man.
Injuries did well.
I had the uh,
the nose thing too.
I had a deviated septum operation.
Let me test for a fucking brilliant
thing.
That is that I'm so happy that doctors
figured out a way to fix your fucking
nose.
He can breathe out of it for people who
have that issue and you can't breed that
he knows.
Take.
If you can set aside some time,
plan it out,
set aside some time to get that shit
fixed.
My God,
that's a freeing feeling.
The first time I can go my whole life.
My nose was useless.
I broke my nose and I was like five.
So my whole life is like a terrible,
oh,
it's the worst.
You're going everywhere.
Not Breathing.
I wonder how many shitty decisions I've
made in my life because I wasn't getting
enough oxygen.
Kidding,
man.
That was a mouth breather is the reason
why they call people mouth breathers and
they think of them as idiots.
This mouth breathing fucking idiot.
It's because of your mouth is open.
You look like it,
it can't look like anything but a
fucking dunce when your mouth is open.
Yeah,
you can't be a bad motherfucker.
You know,
like if your chicks blowing you and
that's your face,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
You're gonna fucking really turned her
off.
I like to put a purposely awful face.
I want to get just a further.
The punishment.
There was a guy that used to post on my
message board,
I don't know if he was telling the truth
or not.
It was a really interesting sort of a
thing because the guy was obviously a
very talented writer and he had a
website where he would write about his
encounters with women and he would set
up these,
uh,
women who are low income women who
needed money.
You mean easy women?
Slowly but surely he would,
uh,
um,
integrate himself into their lives and
start a.
You like having them,
uh,
obligated to him,
like giving them an apartment,
sugar daddy shit.
But he would do it nice and slow and
then he would start getting them to suck
his dick.
And that's how they,
that's how they started paying him
because they didn't have any money.
Like he was gonna call the cops.
I mean this guy like would orchestrate
it.
He would know that they couldn't afford
things and set them up and even even
loan them some money at first to get
things rolling.
And then when they couldn't pay him
back,
he would start saying,
listen,
we're going to work this out.
And he,
he would purposely make his diet
disgusting.
He would eat asparagus and s and drink
black coffee and he had like a bunch of
different things that he would eat to
purposely make his loads disgusting and
cigarettes to some,
I think it was cigarettes.
Do you,
do you remember this guy did this?
Yeah,
people banned.
They banned them eventually from the
message board because he was such a
creep.
But yeah,
he,
you know,
he would have these.
Even if they weren't true stories,
they were brilliantly,
brilliantly written.
It was really interesting.
The writing,
I mean it was like,
it was like the inside the mind of a
total sociopath that is just getting
these poor girls and just doing crazy
shit to them like coming inside the rass
and you know,
while they're,
while they're at work and doing it just
nutty shit.
I forget what he did with everything was
like abuse.
Everything was like swallow his load.
After he ate all this asparagus,
everything was like he just wanted them
to just feel completely demeaned and
then he would move on and go to the next
place.
We had another girl set up channel like
that.
Like I'm a pervert,
like I like to pay for it,
but I never,
I want it to be because we're coming to
an understanding like I'm too average
for you to fuck for free.
Like I don't like it to be predatory
shit.
Like I don't like,
I don't like women are hurt.
I don't like when women feel demeaned.
Like I never want to go to field
demeaned.
You have to take it.
Like I'll actually go,
Nah,
that's fine.
What exactly talking about?
Like it,
it's a great transaction.
We just had,
I never want them to feel degraded.
I don't degrade chicks.
I mean I'm,
I'm a fucking pervert and I like a big
neat pussy and I'm,
that's all I want.
I never want them to feel bad about it.
It,
it's a funny thing man,
because really if they had,
if they had sex with you for free,
there's nothing wrong with it.
You know,
if they decided to give you a blow job
for free,
people do it all day,
all over the world.
But if somehow or another you give them
some money,
then then it becomes a terrible thing
that there are moral and they've made a
decision to get sex for money.
Well,
people always done that,
but women have done that throughout
history.
You know,
there's a lot of ugly dudes.
It's pretty women.
Fuck yeah man.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Now.
Thank God for that.
Pick up chicks on my fucking marriage.
I never fucked a hot chick on my mirror.
So what should we be able to go after a
sugar daddies?
Should we show her women who married
When you see a 20 year old chick,
Marion,
a 55 year old dude,
should we do,
should we,
uh,
should we go after them or is that a
prostitute?
How could you possibly be attracted to
him?
You just want his money.
What did he buy you?
Oh,
we bought you this prostitute right now
of a guy.
Gives a girl watch to fucker.
Is that prostitution?
What does it mean?
Get slippery?
Yeah.
Very,
very slippery.
You mind if I let you fuck me in the
ass?
What do you want?
Yeah,
how many do you want to take tickets?
There's a watch that I really love.
Show me it.
Show me right now and like,
all right,
we got it.
That is the same as a cash transaction.
It is,
it's prostitution.
Men Do that with their wives all the
time,
but a watch costs more like at least for
me,
$300.
I'm out.
Fuck you gonna buy somebody.
I'll watch.
What is the standard going rate for like
is that for getting jerked off as that
for getting blown?
300 bucks.
What is it?
Three and four.
It depends.
If the girls are massage therapist and
not an escort,
sometimes you can get jerked off for
three slash 50.
I spend more than I should,
but I figured,
you know what,
I'm not going to knock a checkup doing
that.
I'm not going to know.
There's gonna be no horrible
repercussions from doing that because
uh,
the amount of money you pay,
if you fucking get somebody pregnant is
18 years,
20 years of tuition and all that.
Fuck that man.
Do you feel weird about letting them
come to your house?
No.
No,
no.
I love him at my house.
It's my space.
I know that there's nobody going to film
me.
I know that nobody's going to take a uh,
rob me.
I know I'm in a secure building.
I had the security of my building.
This fucking a concierge.
It's a very secure place.
Did you get a place and think about the
fact that you're going to bring escorts
back to it so you need certain things
set up it.
Everything I've ever done is somehow or
how many got horse in my house that has
an underground garage.
I'm like,
good,
because I fucking training with the
blonde hair.
I can't have her coming through the
lobby.
You always gotta think of that Shit.
Sure.
That's hilarious man.
But I did the building.
I actually just love it.
I did think that's great that there's
security there because while I liked the
idea of people not knowing my comings
and goings,
I like being safe more and now you're
not going to have anybody act up at a
building with security unless you get
out of line.
But normally they're not going to act up
because they just want to get the money
and fucking go.
Right.
I've had a couple.
I had a scary experience one time I went
to a house to get like jerked off years
ago.
It was right off second avenue and I
walked in and it was like really dark
and she was shady and she was holding a
screwdriver and I went to piss and there
was like a really weird water in the tub
and there was like Burger King rappers
in it.
And uh,
there was fruit flies and I sat down and
it was dark and the rest of the room,
it was a messy house,
like a railroad apartment in New York.
And I felt that something very evil was
in the room and I very rarely if ever
get that feeling,
but I knew there was somebody else in
the room with us and they were just in
the back,
like looking through a door,
I could sense that there was a person
there,
so,
uh,
and she was holding this screwdriver the
whole time and I just started to get
very scared,
like we have these instincts and I
listened to my instincts and I'm like,
look,
uh,
I'm sick.
I can't do this.
But I paid her the money and I just
left.
And I knew I had.
I had dodged a bullet because her hands
were dirty.
There was something that was one of the
scariest moments in my life because I
couldn't see who was the apartment was
again.
It was really a little bit lit when I
walked in,
when I gave him the money,
she went to the door and open it.
She might've just faked handing it to
somebody,
but my sense that somebody was in that
room with us was very,
very strong.
So that was a case and that's why I
don't go to places where I think there
are a lot of them would have Sony in the
movie,
the room with them just for protection
or next door.
Yeah.
A lot of them do,
do,
a lot of them do,
do that,
but I don't think that there'll be a
smart thing to do.
No.
Yeah.
Well they have them within shouting
distance.
But uh,
there was something extra to have them
in the room because you just threatened
me with a screwdriver.
Mr.
Fifty extra for the Philips has dirty
hands who said yeah,
she was just dirty.
It was something fucking shady going on.
I knew it and I felt that I had done
that enough times to know when something
was off,
something was really off and that's why
people get killed because they don't
listen to that instinct.
Wow.
Um,
and I listened to it and I'm not saying
I was going to get killed,
but something bad was gonna happen.
And I absolutely know it.
And then how long did it take before you
wanted to get laid again?
After that?
I probably acted out the next day.
My Dick didn't know what happened.
Like,
Hey,
actually man up plus he,
Jesus Christ.
That was scary.
Yeah.
How did you,
uh,
how did you get out of there?
I just,
I said I think I like,
I have cancer and I'm not feeling well.
And I,
all cancer think I said,
I said some really like I have cancer.
I'm,
I feeling for some really weird thing.
I didn't want to spook her.
Uh,
she,
I remember she had a blonde hair.
It was a wig,
something so wrong.
There was something so raw with,
with what was happening in that house.
And it was just such a gut instinct that
it wasn't just,
there was something fucking.
I had a friend who,
uh,
he,
after he broke up with a girl,
they stayed in touch and they agreed to
a form of prostitution because she was
like,
you know,
she always had like shitty jobs.
She always needed money and she said she
couldn't have a relationship with him
anymore.
She was past it,
but she would come over and let him fuck
her or she would suck his dick and he
would give her money.
It's crazy.
I became,
became a weird sort of a prostitution
thing.
It's like,
it really freaked him out when he was
telling a story.
It's like,
it started off as like she needed to
borrow money and she asked me and I said
yes,
come on over.
And then somehow or another he gave her
the money and then they fucked,
like she,
like,
you know,
thanked him by blowing them or something
like that and you know,
and she said,
you know,
something like,
we can do this anytime,
you know,
anytime you want to do that,
as a,
I always need money,
like joking around.
And I think he gets grabbed and said,
listen,
we don't have to.
There's nothing wrong with this.
I'll,
I'll make you a deal.
You know,
I'll pay you x amount of money and you
come.
And so like he turned her into his
brain.
Is that if you're looking for new
clients,
I would love to have someone who is not
really a prostitute though.
She's only doing it with her ex and she
says so she says she will fucking branch
out franchise.
That shit.
This was,
by the way,
this was over a decade ago,
changed her ways,
but it was a great story when he was
doing it,
like while it was going down I was like,
wow,
that is nuts.
So I couldn't do it with my ex
girlfriend cause I loved her too much,
but I could do it with girls I've dated
in my life like any extra effort was
with for a year and a half.
I could never do that because I would
just feel too sad for them by what if
it's a real nice exchange.
Like you don't feel sad for the regular
prostitute that doesn't even know you
don't want her to feel bad seeing her
and fucking or again,
that will bring back.
You know,
we just couldn't do it.
I would feel too.
Yeah,
that's true.
However,
get a couple of drinks in.
Yeah,
you'd be fine.
No,
but a girl who I've just met once,
like there's one girl who I met through
a friend once who I wound up fucking.
I wanted her for years and I finally got
the fucking like eat her ass for money
and that was awesome.
That was awesome.
Do you wash it off?
How do you handle the eating the ass to
do?
How do you wash it off?
You could put the fuck.
Is he watching?
Oh,
what do you get?
Scraped cheese on your pizza.
Fuck it enough.
Oh my goodness.
Was that no dive right in?
If it's,
again,
it's rare that it's going to be filthy.
If it's a little.
I've had a couple of fucking damaged
ones,
but normally there normally they're
good.
When you're doing the damage,
just fucked off back away.
Maybe I'll clean up the problem or kiss
the cheeks.
Turn Up.
Sometimes you have to.
Don't eat the ass.
If it's dirty,
it's filthy.
It smells moist.
Like I've had a few of those.
You can't do that.
I've had a fuser they grab you then.
Have you ever gotten sick from eating
ass?
No,
but once years ago I worked at caldor
and now when I was in 1997 and there was
a girl who worked in the housewares
department and she came over and we were
doing inventory and she let me eat her
pussy and I didn't want it to fuck for a
long time,
but she had bad breath.
Her breasts,
like corn.
It was like she hadn't eaten in a month
and it was just a kernel of corn riding
in her stomach,
like ever smell corn breath pull.
I pulled.
She had pantyhose on,
which is a bad sign when you're doing
inventory and our pussy fucking re and I
went down and it was so foul that I
think I retched,
but I did go through with it.
I am nothing if not a fucking
professional is the one that is the
worst.
This too,
too terrible smells that are under
three.
The dead body smell tell human dead
bodies.
It's just unbelievably bad.
That's mother nature,
telling you to get the fuck away from
that thing and then there's the smell of
bad pussy and shit,
which are really close,
like a use infection,
like a horrible smelling yeast
infection.
There's almost something more disgusting
about that smell than a shit smell.
Oh yeah.
Vista.
When you fucking and you see that milk,
when you see that frame coding and you
just,
it just begins to really reconnect sour.
Yeah.
That's a terrible,
terrible smell.
Oh Man.
That's an awful smell.
It stinks.
So how do you not know that's coming out
here?
Well,
the thing about smells is that
especially um,
grow smells like all,
all factory sensors detect change.
I don't think they detect like steady
smells.
That's why people live in places where
those factories and shit or you know,
my parents lived near.
I'm a cow.
A places.
Yeah.
Cow poop where the,
they raised like a fucking shitload of
cattle on this one road.
And every time you drive by this robe
you smells couch.
These girls are just doing it all their
whole life.
They've just had dirty pussies.
Well,
I know one girl that I knew when I was
young who had a real problem and
she was a,
I think her parents just kind of raised
her like or like in a box,
like they didn't talk to her about
anything sexual and she didn't know what
the fuck was going on and her box was a
mess.
I mean for,
for like years this girl had on and off
yeast infections.
You that she was molested and kept it
dirty on purposely a lot of times.
Oh,
a lot of chicks get really fat too.
A lot of chicks don't want that pussy to
be good because I don't want you to be
attracted to them.
So a lot of girls.
But I do have your ass dirty just in
case.
They of course have heard that with
women that there's women that overeat
because of that.
They're trying to make themselves look
on the track.
I won't fuck you.
Fuck a fatty ever.
But somebody with a bad pussy.
It depends.
If it's like a yeast infection,
bad.
No,
but sweaty can be again.
Yeah,
right now the gym,
who cares?
I don't fucking right in the fucking
miles you run a little piss smell to it,
but shit,
that's where you draw the line a little
bit.
Not a lot,
but a little bit.
It's an animal thing,
man.
I can't believe you like the underarms,
distinct.
It's a strange thing,
but it's raw.
Like I remember like even when I smoked
my,
uh,
my nose has always been a very vegan.
I was a kid.
I used to lay on my back and my friend
and his sister,
I was in like first grade,
she was in second grade and he was in
Migraine.
She was a year older than us and I would
get them to sit on my face in their
pants because they both would piss their
pants a lot.
I guess they had mortifying home life.
Apparently somebody yelled a lot in the
house,
tinkle in their crotch.
And so I would lay on my back and have
them fucking put their crotch over my
face and I would smell it.
I just love the smell.
I was like,
I swear to God,
I,
I remembered that I would lay behind the
shrubs and have the fucking sit on my
face.
I,
I used to do something as a kid.
I don't know if I told you this before,
but I know you're a,
you love Pete,
but I,
the girl that always wanted me to fuck
her in the shower and then pee inside of
her because it felt like I was coming in
or,
and if you ever done that,
not
in the,
I don't like shower sex because I have,
I'm so high maintenance.
I have to be fucking a certain way and
keys my nipples and it's hard for me to
peanut chick.
Um,
I've pissed on girls,
but it's hard for me to pee in a,
in a girl because,
uh,
it's just such a different sensation to
me.
But I would love to be able to admire
the,
irritates the tip.
I wonder how many women were listening
to this podcast right up as a point
where you got to tease my nipples.
I'm like,
that's it.
That's it.
I've lost a lot of.
I'm done.
I can't listen this guy,
but you know what,
I'll tell you what I do and what I say
and I talk about it as they say.
It weeds out all non hackers who don't
pack the gear to serve my beloved core.
Anybody who is not going to fucking show
up to play,
I,
I probably weed out 90 percent of the
women that would go out with me,
but the 10 percent that show up are
fucking troopers.
Right?
And those are the ones.
And you're famous.
Now,
do it.
Okay.
I mean,
I'm doing well.
I'm not famous yet.
You're famous.
Listen,
I don't feel silly.
Boy,
you're famous.
You're famous.
You're on the opiod.
Anthony show.
Do you know the opening?
Anthony shows one of the greatest radio
shows in the history of the world.
Thank you.
I do.
You're a reason.
You're a big part of that.
You've made me fucking house more times
driving around in my car than any human
alive.
That is a fact.
Oh,
thanks.
There's 100 times.
I mean,
I can't tell you how many times I called
you or texted you.
A particular lines that killed me on the
show.
You're famous,
you know,
it's,
it's a weird thing.
It's a thing that people don't like to
say because you sound like a Douche bag,
you know,
when you say,
yeah,
well I know I'm famous,
you know,
it sounds gross and it feels gross even
think about it,
but you know,
but what my point is you are and you're
famous for being a pervert.
So it's like it's all out on the table.
So it's not like you might have cut out
the amount of women that would a date
you buy,
you know,
90 percent.
But those 10 percent you have 57,000
percent more of them.
Yeah,
no.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
The numbers are staggeringly in your
favor because if you were like a regular
dude that never got famous and kept all
this shit hidden,
it would be really hard to find exactly
what you're looking for and the ones
that you lose that are really pretty or
really cool.
And there's been some that I'm like,
fuck man,
I blow it.
But it's like she would have been,
we would have had an awful sexual
relationship anyway because I know what
I like and you don't have to be filthy,
but you've got to be kind of open and
willing to at least like.
I like talking about a lot of stuff that
I don't like to just sex.
You're not hurting anybody feel like
you're talking about a chick fucking
other guys.
Like I love him and she tells me she'd
rather be fucking another guy.
I'd tell them to pretend they don't even
know what a Dick looks like.
Oh my God.
It's so pretty.
I don't think I know how to suck.
Why should I try?
Would you want me to try?
Yeah,
go ahead and try and make him play dead.
I pretend that they'd been in a
hermetically sealed pouch for 30 years.
Now I like to make a girl watch
something rather fucking tell me how
she'd rather be.
Yeah.
I need a little dose of humiliation is
straightened me out,
man.
You're so honest about though.
It's so much fun.
You must get the craziest girls that
come up to you now.
Don't you?
You get a good amount like I can.
I really.
I hate to even.
I didn't talk about it.
I just on this last tour I did because
I've talked about it so much,
but I like big pussy.
I've always joked about that thick
lipstick lips in a fucking,
a big click like it drives me.
It's a visceral fucking thing.
It makes me crazy.
I remember there was a porn star from
eighties or the eighties and nineties to
del Rio.
No,
no,
no.
Caitlin.
Ashley,
I think her name was.
Anyway,
I forget her last name,
but she had the biggest pussy.
Lips.
They were ridiculous.
They were like hands like,
and they would grab a hold of Dude's
Dick Blick.
Look at the size of her fucking pussy
lips and then I had heard from some
something,
some online,
maybe it was a stern show that some
women get their lobbyists.
Labor reduction.
I think that was doctor should be
targeted like fucking abortion doctors.
I hate those guys.
That was kind of uplifting women.
Those poor women that think that there's
anything wrong with that.
Like that.
It feels good,
all that,
all that is just more pussy.
It's more lips.
They don't get it wrong with it and I
try and I say that it's really,
but women do appreciate that.
Like the fact that I take that stand and
I'm really dirty about it,
but it's like they really do appreciate
the fact that your body.
I love it.
It's like you've got big areolas man.
Fucking giant.
Every Ola.
Nothing wrong with that.
Takes the whole boob.
He just Ariel and I like big kids too.
But you know what?
If you got a cups or Beacopp,
she fucking titchy me.
Big Long nipples.
Nipples.
Like we're like,
oh,
I know.
Not like I like a fucking pussy that had
to be put in a locker,
like someone would change with the
crotch and the locker because they're
embarrassed or the size of the pussy
locking that.
I like,
man.
I worked with this chick once and she
was a very funny and very open and she
was talking about her ex boyfriend that
her ex boyfriend had before you had met
her,
had hooked up with this woman they were
making out.
They were getting all hot and heavy and
then when he pulled her pants down,
her clit was like really long,
like absurdly long,
like a small thumb.
It was just like any panicked and she
responded like she knew that,
you know,
other guys had probably already panicked
and he made up some story about needing
to go to the airport for getting to pick
up his brother.
Hey ran out of her.
He saw her,
her,
her Dick Pussy and just ran out.
I told you on an earlier podcast where I
was so drunk once that I was eating a
girl out and suck her lips.
It would go out so far that I kind of
thought maybe she,
it was a like a bad penis or something
like,
like yeah,
like it was under foreign penis or
something and so I had to like turn on
the light a little and look at it
because it was so.
I mean it was that long coke zero.
It's stretched out like fucking came in
my mouth.
I would fucking love that.
Like I would never be mad.
I had a woman walk up and go like,
I have what you like,
so happy and her pussy.
Then it was just,
it was a fucking giant pack.
It looks like an octopus.
Yeah,
Dude.
It was like indefinable,
like you wouldn't know what it was if
somebody just showed you a picture of it
without a woman attack.
Fuck is that.
You'd have no idea if they get a bunch
of things thrown somewhere.
How bad was it?
The worst one you've ever seen or the
wonderful?
The best one you've ever seen?
The best one I've seen in one of them.
One one was a dominatrix.
I only saw a couple of times many years
ago and one was a massage therapist who
was massaging me,
probably 2002 and I was on my back and
she had shorts and I had convinced her
to go over my face so I could look at
her ass.
I didn't know her pussy and she,
her legs parted and I saw her pussy.
It was literally a fucking belly button
to the spine.
It was the holy grail.
I lost my breath.
I lost my belly button.
You probably choking on it,
dude.
I fucked.
No,
she wouldn't let me do anything.
Eventually she let me lick it and smell
it.
It was like,
it would always snap,
dude.
It was fucking awesome.
We would always fight money when she
would come over,
but she got too greedy.
It's like if she had just thank God she
didn't know she could have owned the
whole franchise.
I would.
Would've signed that.
Well,
this is before I owned my place,
but I would have given her my rent
money.
Like literally she could have owned me,
still new,
but she will always get mad and want
more money and the greed would turn me
off because it was unreasonable.
I felt it was unreasonable,
but her fucking pussy man,
she could only with it.
So the closest you got to eat.
She likes to lick it.
Oh No.
I fucked her a couple times.
I saw him for a couple of years.
Oh.
But it was,
I think around the time that we were
doing tough crowd.
He worked at slowly into fucker.
Yeah.
Oh,
she saw you on tough crowd.
One more money.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
Pretty much.
You don't know what to do.
She,
she had gone with a friend,
a tough crowd or something or I forget
she saw it.
I forget how we get it.
You want to email me randomly?
I just don't remember.
I found online,
it depends,
like fucking 10 years,
but got her pussy.
I can remember like it was yesterday was
wonderful.
Jim Norton,
you're an awesome human being.
Thank you for being you.
I love you man.
And a youtube man.
Can I just plug my special?
Absolutely.
It's on this Saturday.
A June 30th epics and epics hd.com.
It's called please be offended and uh,
I'm very happy with it.
So I hope people dig it.
And uh,
when did you record this?
Uh,
I,
uh,
end of April and Cleveland.
So there's a lot of sand dusky stuff in
it,
which actually still feels timely.
Thank God that's still fucking timely.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
It's perfect.
It's going on right now.
Yeah,
it is.
Uh,
it's just,
it's not a,
he's not even sentenced yet,
so it's still a,
you know,
we'll still feel fresh.
Yeah,
isn't that funny?
I did mine in late April to and it's
just a mad scramble now to make up the
next hour.
It's exciting though,
isn't it?
I love it,
dude.
I love it because I can go on,
like I said at the seller and I'm
talking about the Travolta stuff and all
and again,
then you find this stuff that's topical
where you have to weed it out because it
feels too time sensitive.
Like if I talked about,
I talked about tiger,
my special a little bit,
but the two points I hit on were so
general that had.
You didn't have to remember the case,
but there are the 12 minutes before had
to be cut,
so now I'm in that process with the
Travolta Shit,
like it's already out of the news so I
got to take a couple of moments that
will feel good in six months and just
make them part of the act.
But you're right.
It's fucking great.
I love it.
I can't wait to hear the two volts was
stuff.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
I'm happy with it.
I mean Charlie Sheen Shit.
Last time I saw you in August,
I stopped doing.
Thank you man.
I totally took that because wasn't fresh
anymore.
Yeah.
Got beaten down.
Right.
Is this.
Is this your trailer here?
African American woman.
Nevermind.
Oh No.
That one might've been the way we showed
one of those online.
What?
What number was that when you just
posted today,
I believe.
Oh No.
Show show number.
I'll show you the one they showed on
Leno show number five.
PSA number five.
The psis.
Yeah,
but they showed them on.
They show this one on the tonight show.
They just get a bit.
They left the language in and everything
because none of the clips I wanted to
show,
I just.
I'm too embarrassed to watch myself.
But PSA.
The fifth one,
it's very awkward.
Christian and I was offended by Jim
Norton.
I'm gay and I was offended by Jim
I'm black and I was deeply offended by
Jim Norton that lily white mothers.
Approximately one out of every 10
Americans is offended by Jim Norton.
I'm a Latina and I was offended.
Budget except for the shit he said about
black people.
Yo.
They all got big Dicks,
they showed it unkindly against Jim
Norton and we strongly urge you to
boycott Jim Norton's brand new comedy.
Special needs be offended only on an
index.
And I approved this message.
Fuck,
that's right.
They cut the end.
What's worse than your manager?
Yelling something out on the back of
their bombs when they show it,
but yeah,
they showed.
They showed a unedited.
So we'll see what actually gets through.
So on Epix,
how do they show it on Epix?
Is it sensored at all?
Well,
they are on the network nor the language
from my.
The specials.
These,
they edit on the networks that can show
them in regular time online there
unedited.
And you know my specialist.
Totally.
I know that they were amazing.
Your work,
you're allowed.
You can swear as much as God beautiful.
The opening,
the opening was really fucking cool.
We Got Ozzie to do part of the opening.
Did you fucking see the monstrous Ozzy
Fan?
Yes.
So we got to fucking.
You could show her something like 30
seconds if you want to end on that,
if that's cool,
but don't show the whole opening.
I don't think that's an online yet,
but just the ozzy ozzy twitter did for
me.
They freely come in shambles.
Twitter to.
Yeah.
Wow Dude.
What is it like to grow up loving Ozzy
and then being in a position where you
get to meet the guy.
My fucking ex girlfriend said,
your life is fucking great.
You should never be angry.
Like I've met my after.
After I did this shoot with Ozzy,
it was in his house and it only took 20
minutes and afterwards he goes,
he comes back and he's already been,
God bless you,
and he walks away and then he comes back
and he goes,
Hey Jim,
I want to play something for you.
And he walked me down into his fucking
studio.
It's me and him alone.
His assistant was in the back and he
plays me new sabbath songs sitting with
fucking.
I almost couldn't handle it.
I almost said the.
Can I go home like this is more than I
can handle.
It's probably the single greatest moment
ever had and he was looking over to see
how I reacted to see if I was enjoying
his musical shit.
I sat with Ozzy in his house and listen
to new Sabbath.
It fucking amazing.
It's,
it's so crazy.
I just go to just go to a Ozzy Osborne's
twitter.
They realize you're crazy to idolize
someone when you're young and just to
even get to meet them,
to meet them,
but then to talk to them and to have
them listen to you far to see ozzy
performing new songs for you.
Yeah,
just while we sat there listening to
them,
whether it was it was new songs and to
know that my opinion mattered to him.
I'm like,
he really wanted to know what I thought
of them and it was just some new years,
a few years back and last year was it
Brian?
Jean Simmons came his family,
his son,
liked one of my cds,
came and brought his whole family to New
Year's at the Improv and when I got
there they're like Gene Simmons and his
family is here to see you.
And I was like,
what,
like when I was a little kid,
not only was I a huge kiss fan,
but I was a huge gene simmons fan.
Like he was my favorite when he had the
kiss solo album and the gene simmons.
So,
um,
that was the one I bought when I had
money.
Know the first whatever dollars I could
scrounge up.
I got that one first.
Then I got the feeling.
Yeah.
It wasn't a Christine Sixteen.
Wasn't that on there?
That was off of a love gun.
Love Christine 16 was loved gun.
The one you're talking about.
The Solo had started off with
radioactive and kiss Frito.
Here's,
here's the video back in the New York
group.
Ace freely.
Phenomenal.
Fuck yeah.
Look,
I really,
really need you to do this.
I want to do.
I'm your biggest fan.
I never asked her for anything.
You'll take two seconds.
I'm a little fucking busy right now.
We're not in any rush.
We'll wait.
If I do this one thing when you might be
a big premise.
Sure there are.
You will never ever bother me again.
Me fucking alternatives.
Photographs to your ass.
Any fucking thing?
Yes.
I promise.
I swear.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome to the stage Mr Jim
fucking.
Wow.
That gives me chills.
Is that great though?
Just looking the fact that that happened
for you.
That gives me chills and I got to walk
out,
but that was the reason you hear
laughter because that was shown on a big
screen in front of the audience and I
came out the fucking hole in the sky by
Sabbath him on his toilet introducing
me.
I sent Sharon the fucking email and
does.
She's like,
yeah,
sure.
When he's back from him and we'll do it.
Holy Shit.
That's awesome.
So that's a.
that's a a life moment.
It really is.
It's one of the greatest moment of my
life.
Fuck Rachel.
Thank you.
It's amazing.
Thank you very much for being here.
Thank you.
Awesome man.
Anytime you're in La,
please come by any time.
And your book is also hilarious.
Chapter with Patrice,
getting hookers in Brazil.
That happy endings.
Happy endings.
Steve Martin actually called me out on
bashing him and fucking.
Are you seeing mostly?
Yeah,
I was doing a tonight show a bit for the
and Steve Martin
and his band came up and I'm like I said
to my project,
I don't know if he'll talk to me,
but he didn't recognize my face when he
saw my name on the CD goes.
You said some very unkind things about
me in your book and I actually felt
really bad.
What did he say?
What'd you say about I just trashed them
for doing the Pink Panther,
but the book was about targeting fucking
Sharpton and Jesse Jackson and Keith
Olbermann who I thought turned on Ims
for language.
It was about that shit.
So I had missed misguided anger towards
Steve Martin.
I should have made fun of them and it
shouldn't have been as mean.
And I actually did feel bad about it.
It's hard.
It's hard when you've got to face.
I'm sorry.
I felt like I had uh,
Jenny Mccarthy joke and I met her and
she's so nice.
I stopped doing it.
Yeah,
it's easy to track people to meet them
and they're nice thing,
like a Douche bag.
I'm like,
why am I making fun of her?
Yeah.
Anyway,
by the end of the show,
follow Jim Online on twitter.
Jim Norton.
And what is your facebook?
Just to Jim Norton just to go to twitter
because I don't do facebook much more.
Twitter.
Jim Norton Dot Com.
Jim Warren Dotcom,
which is being put up now.
We finally got it from a cyber squatters
powerful and this weekend.
This weekend?
Yes.
Epics and epics.
Hd Dot com.
If you don't have that time is on again,
10:00
PM on Saturday.
Ten PM on Saturday.
Set your dvr is dirty.
Bitches to Norton.
One of the best comics in the country.
Last time I saw you in Austin,
it was a fucking a beautiful treat for
me to the town and not have to work and
a laugh my fucking ass off.
And I,
I changed a little bit about my act
because of seeing that because you did
about 55 minutes and I'm like,
why am I doing these asshole to our
sets?
You crushed for 55 minutes is the
perfect amount of time.
Know it was really fun,
man.
Thank you man.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that's it for this show.
You crazy bitches.
Thanks to Sucker Punch entertainment for
hookups up on the sweet deal for these
monster alien ware computers,
which we're going to keep supporting
alienware because they support mma
fighters.
And um,
I think that's very important.
So that's why the show is run by
alienware.
Uh,
thanks to the fleshlight.
Please go to Joe Rogan.net.
If you're interested in masturbating
into anything other than the hand and
click on the link for the flashlight and
entering the code name Brogan,
you will save yourself 15 percent off.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com with
the makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
and now kettle bells and battle ropes.
Soon to come.
We got hemp protein and all sorts of the
good shit.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
That's [inaudible] it.
Use the code name Rogan and save
yourself 10 percent off.
All right,
you dirty bitch.
Say I.
If we were going to be at comic con
2012,
I don't know if you might even be going
to try to do that.
Tickets are on sale at death squad.
That TV.
And we have to ask about Joe Friday.
It's almost sold out though.
Yeah,
that's right.
Bitches this Friday.
We don't even know who's there on the
show.
Randy Wallace is returning Brendan and
lick.
He wants to talk to you.
Yes.
Uh,
so.
And Davey Johnson so far.
Tell Randy I just got my black belt.
I'm not fucking around.
You want to get crazy,
randy?
You son of a bitch.
Um,
people don't even know what the fuck
we're talking.
We'd watch Friday.
You'll figure it out.
Maybe not.
We don't know what's going to happen.
Actually a pulled muscle.
I probably shouldn't even do what I
wanted to do.
Um,
but uh,
anyway,
that's uh,
that's the end of the show.
You fucking freaks.
If you want to go to this ice.
Our show go to [inaudible] house
comedy.com.
There's very few tickets left.
It's only a 150 seat place,
but it's awesome.
It's one of the best clubs in the
country.
You ever worked the Ice House?
Jim Norton?
I have not.
I did a Sunday night there and I just
did a quick set and what's his name?
Bumped me.
I'm one of the fucking blue collar guys.
Me?
Yeah,
but he was.
He was pleasant about it.
Oh,
the ice house.
Which is the one I'm thinking of.
Comedy Magic.
No,
this is the ice.
I've never worried.
Oh No.
There was one.
I had an argument with the lady here
because they wouldn't put out the open
mic next door.
The greatest.
Oh,
I would actually love to work here now.
Anytime we'll get you in.
We'll get is the greatest club in the
world.
I would love to work.
This is amazing.
It's just like all those other small.
It's been here for 15 years.
Right there.
You know,
man,
I got to go back and do.
How do they actually got damaged?
Him?
Jim Norton.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please follow him.
Please continue to do the right thing.
Ladies and gentlemen,
follow the correct path and go out there
and fucking be positive and go jerk off
and your mother's face.
O or an a fleshlight.
Then dump it on us.
That's.
No,
don't do that.
Don't shout,
don't jerk off in your mother's face.
I take that back.
Take that back.
You guys were awesome.
We'll see you soon.
Oh,
Friday.
Adam score.
Tease the next podcast.
This Friday.
We'll probably be doing that right
before we do the icehouse chronicles,
which is only available at death squad
on itunes.
You can go to [inaudible] dot TV to buy
tickets for that crazy show and that's
it.
Fucking shows up.
All right.
Bye.
We love you guys.
Mm.